hello everyone welcome to the february
2022 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll uh it's been a while since we've
done an ama since i do them every month
except for january so the last one we
did was the beginning of december
um and things have happened right i was
in boston last time we were doing an ama
and now i'm back in los angeles
i have handed in
the
draft manuscript for my next book which
will be volume one of the biggest ideas
in the universe series volume one is
going to be called space time and motion
and that's basically classical physics
uh broadly construed so for those of you
who don't know the biggest ideas gimmick
is i'm going to be teaching
what i consider to be the biggest ideas
in physics even though i say it's in the
universe it's mostly physics we're
talking about a little bit of math in
there um and the gimmick is that
you aren't supposed to
know any math or physics coming in it is
for a very broad audience but i will
teach you the math so this is going to
be a textbook that not a textbook sorry
certainly not a textbook a book a trade
book a popular book
that is not afraid of doing the
equations and the trick there is that
i'm not trying to teach you how to be a
physicist i'm not teaching you how to
solve the equations like a working
physicist or mathematician would have to
do i just want you to understand what
the equations are saying and that's
actually enormously easier as it turns
out so i will teach you what a
derivative is and what an integral is
and what vectors are and what tensors
are
and with that we'll go pretty far we go
through newtonian mechanics of course
but also
hamiltonian mechanics lagrangian
mechanics and the principle of least
action special relativity general
relativity einstein's equation black
holes the short shield solution with the
equations there so you have to be
a little bit interested a little bit
motivated to do it but i've been trying
really really hard to make it as
understandable as i can it certainly
requires some effort on the part of the
reader but i think that if you're
willing to put in the effort almost
anyone should be able to grasp this
stuff at a real quantitative level
i mean there's two
obvious
comparison books out there already one
is leonard huskins series on the
theoretical minimum
the difference between my approach and
suskins is that
he is kind of doing a more or less
standard physics curriculum kind of
thing you know here is newtonian
mechanics and there is electromagnetism
there's special relativity and quantum
mechanics and so forth um so the topics
are a little bit different because i can
go faster
because i don't need to worry about
teaching you to be a working physicist
right so it's not just physics 101
physics 102 etc i can be a little bit
more philosophical talk about big
picture ideas about space and time and
what have you but i can also get up to
black holes pretty easily which uh never
happens general relativity as far as i
know is not part of the theoretical
minimum series and certainly in uh this
is only volume one of my series volume
two etc will have quantum field theory
and other things like that that are not
in suskin's books
as awesome as they are i love those
books but it's a different kind of thing
the other obvious comparison is with
roger penrose's book the road to reality
uh which does do a lot of things
i would say it does it in slightly
quirky way what can i tell you
again a brilliant wonderful book i think
it'd be hard for most people who didn't
really know the math ahead of time to
start from the beginning and go through
that so i'm both trying to be super
duper pedagogical and understandable
and also trying to get to modern physics
i want you to know the basic ideas that
a second year graduate student in
theoretical physics would know you're
not as facile not as deep as a graduate
student who's doing problem sets all the
time but you will hear the words and
understand them and know what they mean
and be able to look at the equations
that bring those words to rigorous life
and understand those as well that's the
idea anyway so
it is scheduled to come out in september
of this year there's already an amazon
page
if you want to go check it out the cover
is not available yet but you know the
book is there you could pre-order it we
encourage people to pre-order the books
that always gets people excited
bookstores etc
so anyway what i was saying was i handed
in the manuscript early december my
editor read it got comments back to me
late december
i've made revisions on it and handed
those in and i handed those in just a
couple days ago that's why this ama is
getting to you a little bit later than i
would like because i've been working on
edits for the book and it's very
exciting like you know sometimes when
you're explaining something and you
think you got it right and it's
understandable it's a really really good
feeling other times i'm like are they
really gonna understand raising and
lowering indices this is this is weird
this is a little bit of abstraction that
you don't usually get in uh typical
physics books but i think that you know
just knowing what derivatives are what
partial derivatives are which you need
to get to hamiltonian mechanics it
really changes your views on life and i
want to share it more widely
so even if the physics in this
series of books is hit or miss hopefully
you will appreciate the mathematical
language and concepts that are used
there especially if you're not a
professional physicist
hopefully it will be useful that's the
idea anyway i just wanted to get that
off my chest to explain to you why this
ama is a couple days late and i think
that's all i wanted to say about that so
for those of you who don't know for
those of you who are new to this whole
process these ask me anything episodes
happen 11 times a year every month other
than january
and the questions are asked by patreon
supporters of mindscape so you can go to
patreon.com sean m carroll if you want
to become a patreon supporter if you do
become a patreon supporter you get
ad-free versions of the regular podcasts
plus you get to ask questions here at
the amas i don't get to answer
everyone's question sorry about that um
they're all usually good but sometimes i
just don't have anything interesting to
say that's usually why i leave the
question out i'm just not inspired to
say anything interesting about that and
who wants i don't want to waste people's
time
by reading a question and saying no i
don't have anything interesting to say
about it or or insult the questioner i'd
rather just skip that question entirely
feel free to try again the next month
you know i'm not guaranteeing that i
will
uh do it next month but you can keep
trying there's no rule about trying
again and again uh since it's been a
couple of months since you've done it i
will try to go a little bit longer this
time i know i already go pretty long i
do have a tendency to do that uh but we
gotta get some more questions in there
so let's stop wasting our time let's go
[Music]
rodrigo nader says i always tend to
understand the emergence phenomenon as a
consequence of pattern recognition the
creamed coffee example shows that after
mixing many different combinations of
particles look the same a pattern
emerges to us
maybe an alien life form who recognizes
completely different sorts of patterns
would see different macroscopic states
after mixing is emergence really a
property of nature could you give some
other examples to clarify that so i
think it's a very important question
because i think a lot of people do have
exactly the impression that you have
rodrigo but i think it's not correct i
would have to disagree with this uh that
is why dan dennett calls emergence real
patterns is the word real there that
really matters it's not an observer
dependent phenomenon for a couple of
reasons one reason is that there aren't
any aliens or any robots or anything
like that that will see radically
different things when they look at the
cream and the coffee mixing together
than we human beings do it could be a
little bit different if they're subject
or if they're sensitive to different
wavelengths of light or something like
that but it will always be the case that
only you know some tiny number of
photons relatively speaking are carrying
information from the cream and coffee to
your eyeball way way insufficient to
give you access to the specific
locations and velocities of all the
molecules of cream and coffee so there's
a physical fact about what is observably
accessible to you that points us in the
direction of coarse graining the system
in a certain way the other thing which
is even way more important i would say
or also very important is that the
information you do get is useful
it's the information you need even
though it is coarse-grained to say
something about what will happen next so
in other words the best example ever of
emergence is the relationship between
kinetic theory of atoms and molecules
and fluid mechanics or the gas mechanics
if you want right you can take a box of
gas you can describe it in terms of
atoms or you can describe it in terms of
a fluid and that's an emergence
phenomenon the fluid description is
completely different its ontology is
different right it says there's a fluid
in the box as opposed to the atomic
description that says there's a
collection of particles in the box and
there is a perfectly well-known map from
the set of configurations in the atomic
description
do a set of configurations in the fluid
description you can coarse grain very
very literally that's not always
possible but in the box of gas it is
and finally
the information that you're left with by
that coarse graining
namely let's say you pick some coarse
graining size you know cubic millimeter
or whatever in every cubic millimeter of
the book of the box you have a
temperature density pressure things like
that
and that information is enough to
predict how the gas will behave to very
very good accuracy that's what you do
when you model the climate or the
atmosphere right or when you're modeling
a jet exhaust or anything like that
you're doing fluid mechanics even though
you know it's really atoms underneath
and that is an objectively true fact
that even though you have a tiny tiny
fraction of all the microscopic
information in the system it is still
enough to make interesting predictions
if you took random subsets of the
information you would not be able to use
that to make interesting predictions but
the particular information you get from
that course grading operation does give
you enough information to make
predictions
that's a crucial aspect of emergence i
don't think we have
the once and for all theory of
everything as far as emergence is
concerned theory of emergence everything
um but i think these two aspects are
both crucial and there and non-generic
you know you wouldn't expect necessarily
that you could observe a certain subset
of the information of the system and
have that information be enough to
predict what's going to happen next in
general you know if you just had random
things you could observe but in the real
world we see it again and again so
that's a very deep feature of the real
world that i think calls out for some
kind of explanation
rob griber says
i've been listening to early episodes of
the podcast and really enjoyed your
conversation with cornell west my
question for you relates to one of
professor west's closing comments you
ask him what is it that unsettles you i
won't quote his answer entirely but he
starts with well it's what hangs in my
closet and is one of the themes of my
writings really for the last 30 years
which is nihilism
and it comes in different forms there's
secular forms of it there's religious
forms he goes on to link the idea of
nihilism today
to the disconnectedness of the late
modern world it's all about posing
posturing spectacle image
trying to manipulate in order to pursue
our career as our next opportunity i'd
be curious to hear what you thought of
that exchange but more i'd be i'd like
to put that question to you in these
strange pre-post-pandemic times as
politics and social media pull apart
even as signs and innovation blows
forward what unsettles you and what
gives you hope
um
yeah no that's a great question it's a
very thoughtful question i'm sure i'm
not going to be able to do justice to it
it's not something i really thought
carefully about but i can give you my
immediate
impressions um
i get
the fretting about
nihilism uh nihilism just being you know
a conviction that everything is
meaningless right nothing really matters
etc this is part of why i wrote the big
picture to establish you don't need to
be nihilist even if you're a naturalist
i guess i would worry a little bit or i
would wonder let's put it that way
how
accurate the worry is that nihilism is
something
connected to the modern world
specifically like there's more nihilism
now than there was before um i guess it
depends on what you mean by nihilism i
mean there is a sort of disenchantment
in our view of the world we used to have
a picture of the world that was much
more
convict convinced that there were
spirits and purposes and natures out
there in the world and those have gone
away
um but they there never were such
spirits or or purposes so
uh that was wrong and i'm glad to be
correct i'm glad to have improved our
understanding of the world i don't
consider that to be a loss
um and i consider the real purposes and
meanings that are there in the world
come from human beings just as they
always did so i'm not i would have to
see like a careful
scholarly
investigation this question of has
nihilism become more of a problem in the
modern world than it was or
if it is more of a problem is it a worse
problem than what it has replaced let's
put it that way
um your your harder question is
what is it that unsettles me you know
that's what i hope was hoping no one
would ask
uh but you know look i i'm not gonna say
anything original or uh or new i i talk
about the things that unsettle me all
the time i guess if i have to pick one
it's the uh gradual disintegration of
our ability to act like a democracy
and i know that people are going to say
that we never really worry democracy etc
fine okay i mean democracy in the united
states and elsewhere in the world has
always been the sub
ideal uh it's always fallen short of
what you might want it to be it's still
better in my mind than any of the
alternatives and i'm extraordinarily
worried that it's not going to last much
longer we know it doesn't always last
democracy sort of
appears and disappears historically and
there's no reason to think that we
should necessarily be different
and i also think it's perfectly obvious
that here in the united states if you
have like republicans and democrats
one side is far and away more
responsible for the threats to democracy
namely the republicans in case you're
wondering than the democrats are
but i absolutely think that all sides
are
falling short in worrisome ways okay
in the following sense that if you think
that democracy
is good if you want it to work if you
want to be a success
you have to be committed to the ideal of
working with people with whom you
disagree
and that's the ideal that i think is
just disappearing on both sides
it will always be true that some people
with whom you disagree you disagree with
them so strongly
that they're not
in any sense partners they are just the
enemy right you can only fight them
you're not trying to work with them um
but if that's most other people or if
that's half the country then you don't
have a functioning democracy and you
won't
if you consider half the country to be
your enemy then you're then there's no
way for democracy to work under those
circumstances and i i'm worried that
more and more people think that way on
both sides um if you're pro-democracy
the question you should be asking
yourself is
how far can someone go to be on the
other side to be on the side i disagree
with and yet i will still work with them
right and this is not an easy question
i'm not trying to simplify it you know
we we can always remember the podcast
with teen wen where he warns you against
oversimplifying uh looking for false
clarity in these complicated um social
situations
it's not simple to say these people are
not worth engaging with and these people
are but the point i'm making is
you have to be able to engage with
people who you don't like who you don't
agree with but nevertheless they're your
fellow citizens and you have to work
with them somehow and that's becoming
increasingly harder you don't make peace
treaties with your friends you make
peace treaties with your enemies um
that's my that's my biggest worry that's
what unsettles me that in many ways
people don't want to
talk to each other they don't want to
understand each other they don't want to
agree to disagree they just want to
fight and they just want to you know
have a quote unquote democracy by
assuming that their their views should
be the ones everyone votes for now of
course it's also okay in the context of
democracy to work to change people's
minds that's crucially important that's
a very high priority thing to do so it's
not only that you have to work with
people you disagree with but you have to
try to convince them to agree with you
but that second thing convincing them to
agree with you won't always work
there are people with fundamentally
different values and we have to be
devoted to finding a way to live
together i'm not so sure we are devoted
that way i'm not even so sure that we
try
to um attain that goal anymore that kind
of unsettles me
you also ask what gives me hope uh you
know what gives me hope let me give you
a very silly answer and self-serving
answer what gives me hope is that so
many people listen to podcasts like this
and not just because it's it's my
podcast what gives me hope is that
i do find empirically that when you give
people
good ideas good information
thoughtful things to chew over
they are surprisingly interested in
tackling big ideas you know i think that
people
like to say that other people are just
stupid and they just want to watch
reality shows or whatever and sometimes
they do i don't even mind watching a
reality show in the right place right
time you know um
uh what is it masterchef junior come on
this is genius i would always watch
master chef junior but it can't be
everything that you do and i you know i
think that we underestimate the public
sometimes in terms of
intellectual engagement that's one of
the reasons why i'm writing the book
right um the biggest ideas books i'm
trying to provide it's not going to be
you know number one bestseller uh given
what is inside the book but i think that
there are more people than we usually
think who are willing to dig into
equations and learn some physics
likewise i think there are more people
who than we usually think who are
willing to think hard about philosophy
or or politics or economics or the
climate or whatever that's what gives me
hope is that when we give people
the chance to engage with ideas and
thoughtful ways uh more than you might
guess they leap at the chance
all right bruno texiera says i don't
understand what you mean by maybe dark
energy is just the cosmological constant
especially when opposed to other
hypotheses related to quantum fields
isn't gr a classical emergent
description of a fundamentally quantum
phenomenon when we figure out quantum
gravity won't dark energy be something
in that model
well i mean maybe sure i don't know what
quantum gravity is yet so that's uh hard
to predict exactly what's going to
happen but that is completely compatible
with dark energy being the cosmological
constant like like you just said gr is a
classical emerging description of a
fundamentally quantum phenomenon but
emergent descriptions can be correct
general relativity is a very very good
fit for what happens in cosmology so
when i say dark energy is just the
cosmological constant i mean in
at the level of emergent description
where we're describing the universe
as a curve space time obeying the rules
of general relativity i think genera the
vacuum energy the dark energy is going
to be a cosmological constant rather
than a modification of einstein's
equation or some dynamical thing or
something like that what the question
you're asking is you know
how do we explain that value of the
emerging cosmos constant at some deeper
quantum level that i don't know that i
would love to know that if i knew that
be writing a paper on that don't have
any good ideas right now
paul torek says joshua green claimed
that when we use slow careful moral
thought processes rather than quick gut
reactions we'll get utilitarian
conclusions thus ethics gets simplified
to a single dimension of happiness but
does that preference for simple theories
only make sense when one views morality
as a platonic realm out there
independent of human concerns how
plausible is it to you as a moral
constructivist that morality would be so
vastly simpler than the human beings who
construct it
well i think there's a couple of
parts of that question that i would i
would take
i would worry that are not quite an
accurate description i i don't think
that if you ask josh green uh what he
meant by utilitarianism he would say
ethics gets simplified to a single
dimension of happiness i think he would
say it's much more
nuanced than that now it is true that
utilitarianism is based on the idea
there is something called utility
that we try to maximize but by itself
that statement there's a number called
utility we try to maximize uh is almost
content-free because if you have any
rules for any process of making a
decision right uh should i go left to
right should i you know save this person
from drowning or save myself whatever
you know should i you know push the
lever on the trolley problem any
decision-making algorithm
can always mathematically
be cast as maximizing some number and
then you can call that utility right so
it's almost an empty statement to say
you should maximize some number called
utility until you tell people what the
utility is
and it's true that back in the early
days of utilitarianism it was thought to
be happiness or something like that but
more modern sophisticated approaches to
utilitarianism or even going back to jon
stewart mill
they had more sophisticated approaches
for what was meant by utility
now one of the reasons why i'm skeptical
of utilitarianism myself is because even
though you can be more
sophisticated in defining utility
you're still imagining in in practice in
utilitarian practice you're still
imagining that there is some quantity
that you can add up
over different people right so this
person has a certain utility that person
has a certain utility etcetera or this
action as a certain tool you just add
them up and maximize that so it's a
little bit more specific than just
saying you're maximizing something
there's some procedure finding this
thing that you're maximizing
that's what i'm a little bit skeptical
about whether that there's this some
quantity that i can compare one person's
utility to another person's utility in a
way that i could add them together you
know in some linear fashion that that
worries me about that particular step
um but one of the points that josh made
which i thought was an interesting and
important one is that in these more
sophisticated versions of utilitarianism
you know it can almost seem like
uh virtue ethics or deontology or
something like that depending on where
you get your utility from you know maybe
you get your utility from following
rules
if you literally said that all of my
utility comes from following these rules
and not breaking them
then you're both a utilitarian and a
deontological uh moral person at the
same time right so that that sense is
that utilitarianism is pretty flexible
uh and and you can imagine versions a
lot of different versions of it so on
the one hand that makes me more
sympathetic to the idea that it might
work on the other hand it makes it much
more loosey-goosey and maybe less useful
because we don't necessarily haven't
pinned down exactly what we mean by
utility
so anyway my answer to your question is
i don't think it's necessarily true
that utilitarian morality is vastly
simpler
is so vastly simple as you make it out
to be that's not to say that i think
it's a useful way of thinking about
things
but it's potentially useful let's put it
that way i think that i would grant them
that
paul briddick says
the determinist approach proposes that
all behavior has a cause and is thus
predictable and therefore free will is
an illusion a theoretical supercomputer
is programmed to account for all
particle behavior in the vein of
laplace's demon and predict the future
of all behaviors going forward in the
universe if this computer predicts you
will drink coffee for breakfast tomorrow
are you powerless to switch to tea
um so there's a whole bunch of things
going on here packed into a small
package so let me unpack a little bit um
determinism is probably not right
as an operational question for our
universe first off right there is
quantum mechanics we have no
clue whatsoever
uh in fact we have very strong evidence
that it's not possible to have a
complete
quantum state description of the
universe and deterministically predict
what will happen next what will be
observed next um
all of the indications you can't do that
there's some intrinsic randomness there
now some of us like myself believe that
there is a deeper
explanation that involves not just the
world we observe but other worlds also
and the quantum state of the whole
picture is deterministic
but that doesn't help you make
predictions for what's going to happen
next and it's still impossible in
practice
other people who i don't agree with but
they're out there some of my best
friends
think there's only one world but there's
some hidden way that there is
information that does deterministically
predict what will happen next
but even those people
will be very quick to say you don't know
and will never will know what that
information is
so to grant you the question we have to
imagine that there is
a version of quantum mechanics that
really is deterministic and that you're
telling your theoretical supercomputer
information about the universe that no
human being will ever be able to know
okay so let's say that and furthermore
we have to imagine that your theoretical
supercomputer is not within the universe
there are uh problems with
self-reference janae and ismail just
wrote a very interesting article in uh
eon i think uh online that you can read
about this that it's it's there are sort
of problems in in practice and sorry in
principle i should say with imagining a
perfect predictor within the universe
that tries to predict the universe that
it's within because it has to predict
itself and there are sort of
loops and paradoxes that it gets into so
again to make sense of your question we
have to imagine that
not only are there deterministic laws
that are known to the computer but the
computer itself is outside our universe
for whatever reason but if we grant you
all that then yes i am powerless to
switch to d that would be my answer
varun nara simashar says
thank you for your illuminating
conversation with david reich you
touched upon indo-european history and
my question is about that are lay people
in america and elsewhere aware of the
current cultural movement of hindu
nationalism it is advertised as a
revival of bygone glory but in reality i
find it to be rife with jingoism
exclusionism and a flagrant historical
revisionism that flies in the face of
the academic consensus on archaeology
genetics etc i worry for india and i
believe the entire civilized world
should worry about such a
counterproductive phenomenon taking hold
of a globally important democracy
it's a good question i'm not
really
familiar at a data-driven evidence-based
level with how familiar americans are
with these different questions my
suspicion is
that they've heard of hindu nationalism
in india and they don't like it you know
we have our own nationalism here people
wear these red hats saying make america
great again and keep the immigrants out
right and we think some of us think that
our nationalism is terrible others are
all for it but it's much easier to be
horrified in other countries nationalism
right even if you think your own
country's nationalism is pretty awesome
so i don't think that many americans are
in favor of a resurgence of hindu
nationalism in india
we think that other countries should be
you know open and cosmopolitan and get
along with all different sorts of um
cultures within their their societies
even if we have trouble living up to
that
so
i mean i agree i don't have anything
wise to say about this i you know i
think that india is a crucially
important country for the world
um i think that you know it it has a
sort of mixed history with democracy it
is a democracy but not always a perfect
one again you could say the same thing
about the us
um and uh it is not you know as wealthy
as the us or some european countries and
you know there's every reason to think
that it kind of should be in some global
sense so you can imagine there's very uh
uh understandable frustration why it's
not
and when you're in situations like that
where you don't think that your economy
or your living conditions or your global
power is as elevated as it should be
you know you take out your frustrations
in the wrong directions and nationalism
and populism are very common bad places
for that to go so i don't have any
wisdom specific to india but i can
absolutely see the similarities between
what's happening there and what's
happening to other places in the world
preston justice says i've just finished
stephen pinker's new book rationality
what it is why it seems scarce and why
it matters what are your thoughts on the
arduous task of being more rational
amidst the constant storm of cognitive
biases with which we each must contend
more precisely how can the average
josephine pragmatically increase their
rationality points to avoid the
illogical and sometimes deadly
acceptance of quackery and flapdoodle
that perpetually surrounds us
uh yeah i mean these are all good
questions these are constant questions
they're not going away we can all strive
to be better at this i know i work to
try to be better at this we have had
discussions here on mindscape about
precisely these questions uh
maybe most recently with julia galiff
who wrote a book on it on the scout
mindset
and
you know i like julia's book
in particular because it is exactly
addressed to this question of how i can
be
more rational rather than why aren't
other people more rational which is you
know that's a very common book that
people write a lot of the time
um but you know what where i where i
sort of get off the train a little bit
here is near the end of your question
um
where you're talking about quackery and
flapdoodle flop flop doodle i don't know
if i've heard that one i think it's flap
doodle anyway
um
i mean nobody intentionally
uh accepts quackery and flapdoodle
right they all think that they're being
rational and there there's sort of a
level of irrationality that we usually
associate with words like quackery and
flapdoodle that is so irrational that if
you're spending your time worrying about
your cognitive biases you're probably
not
susceptible to that particular brand of
quackery and flapdoodle
but there are other kinds of
irrationality that you can be
susceptible to even though you know that
astrology is not correct or bigfoot
doesn't exist or whatever uh there are
ways of justifying your choices your
attitude towards other people that are
deep down just as irrational but don't
have like the big
shining neon light saying this is
quackery on them
i have no short and simple rules for
doing that i mean one warning sign is if
people say
you know cognitive biases sure are bad
i'm glad i don't have any
then you know that person is not being
rational if you think that you have no
biases that you're completely objective
that you have no tribal affiliations or
identities you're not being honest with
yourself right even if you think that
you shouldn't
even if you think that you should work
to minimize those aspects of how you
think you have to admit that they're
there and stand up to them and recognize
them rather than just deny their
existence uh so recognizing what our
biases are is certainly one of the
biggest steps and one you know again one
very obvious thing is
what beliefs are
in your best interests right what are
the things that you believe are true
which just happen to flatter your own
view of yourself or make yourself look
good right those are always the danger
points i don't want to get into
specifics because every case is
different but uh read julia's book or
listen to that podcast
herbert berkowitz says is cern tourist
friendly uh i think pretty much it is
actually uh cern the giant particle
accelerator laboratory in outside geneva
in geneva yeah maybe part of it is in
geneva um
uh i've visited several times cern but
of course i visited there as a physicist
so i have not visited as a tourist so
i'm not quite sure
how much there is to do i know there are
exhibits and things like that there are
absolutely public available places um
but two things to note number one you're
not going to get to see a particle
detector they're not going to take you
down
beneath the ground to see
atlas or um cms or something like that
uh because they're all sealed up or
physicists are working on them uh
actually if you happen to be there while
things are um
being renovated well you know it's down
time and the machine is opened up then
maybe you could but i still don't think
that's a kind of public available thing
what there are exhibits almost like
museum kinds of exhibits the other thing
is that you know to the working
physicist
uh cern is a bunch of offices right now
when i'm at cern visiting the theory
group it's not a place that any tourists
want to see it doesn't look any
different than visiting caltech or
whatever but again there are you know
public facing sides of it so if you
happen to be in the area i wouldn't
visit geneva just to visit cern but if
you're in geneva
in between looking at the watch
factories and the banks and so forth and
the lake a visit to cern would be a lot
of fun
okay i'm going to group two questions
together here which we sometimes do one
is from kathy seeger who says what
actually happens during entanglement
as it is no classical interaction of any
kind how can it best be described is it
the same kind of process for particles
slash massless particles and local
non-local or are there different types
of entanglement and then george robinson
asks what principle determines how and
when quantum states become entangled i
read sometimes particles get entangled
sometimes they don't but what is the
theory of wave functions that says when
and why the entanglement necessarily
happens um i worry that for both these
questions which are both basically
asking how does entanglement happen um
i'm not going to give a very satisfying
question or answer here because
i don't know there's nothing
entanglement is kind of the natural
state right so the point of quantum
mechanics is that unlike classical
mechanics where you say you have a bunch
of particles every particle has a
position every particle has a momentum
in quantum mechanics you say i have a
bunch of particles every particle
has a possible position that it could
have right it could have a position that
i could possibly measure it to be in
and the wave function assigns a number
complex number to every possible
configuration of all the particles
so nowhere in quantum mechanics is there
the idea that an individual particle
should have its own separate wave
function right there's just a wave
function for the whole collection
it's a very very special case
where you have one particle
where the wave function for all the
particles takes the form
the wave function for one particle times
the wave function for all the others
sometimes that happens but that's kind
of very special if you think about all
the different ways that the big wave
function could depend on all the
variables that's a very specific special
way and that's the case where that first
particle is unentangled with the rest of
the particles
so entanglement is by all means the
generic case uh in the space of all
possible quantum goings-on
that's hidden from us that that feature
of quantum mechanics is hidden from us
in some sense because
we live in a world which is big and
macroscopic and the things that we can
observe are sort of deep into the
classical regime where for all intents
and purposes the entanglement is
negligible okay we don't see
things carefully enough to notice that
they're entangled with other things you
wouldn't notice by looking at one but
you could do complicated experiments
looking at many and
after the fact infer that there was some
entanglement there
so having said all that when do things
become entangled
most of the time
is the answer uh at the quantum level
most of the time if i have two electrons
and i scatter them right so the two
electrons will repel each other by the
electromagnetic force if they were
classical point particles
you would find out exactly what their
positions were exactly what their
velocities were and predict exactly how
they would scatter
since they're not
there is a wave function for both the
particles a function of both their
positions okay let's say
and i can start them off as little wave
packets i can't localize the individual
electrons perfectly but they can be
almost localized they can you'll be like
a bump in one area of space and the two
bumps are heading toward each other
but then what you predict when they
scatter is not some definite angle at
which they scatter but the wave function
for the two of them becomes entangled
and there is sort of a probability that
one particle goes off in one direction
and the other goes off the other and the
same thing is true for all the other
directions so instantly just from two
charged particles bumping into each
other entanglement has occurred
or if one particle all by itself like
the higgs boson let's say
or for that matter a pion a higgs boson
or a neutral pion
uh are both cases of single particles so
there's no entanglement that you're
talking about you just have one particle
nothing for it to entangle with but it
decays okay
both a photon a pion and a higgs boson
can decay into two photons moving off
back to back
what direction are you moving off in i
mean there's no way to pick a special
direction because they're just single
spinless particles sitting there
the answer is they move off in every
possible direction the two photons that
are created and they're entangled with
each other so you don't know which
direction either one photon is moving
off in but you know that if one photon
is moving in one direction the other is
moving in the opposite direction because
the overall momentum is conserved so the
short answer is entanglement happens all
the time the more difficult question
which i'm glad you didn't ask is why do
things look unentangled do we big
macroscopic observers but that has to do
with the classical limit and so forth
and so on i hope that's shedding some
light on the question
frederick axthorn says enough with the
physics already good i'm with you
frederick
me and my friends are coming over from
sweden this summer to stay at the aria
in vegas for two weeks we'd love to hear
your general thoughts on playing poker
in vegas dining and general
entertainment uh well i have many
thoughts
most of which are
be willing to spend money
it makes your visit to vegas a lot more
fun if you're willing to spend money you
don't expect to make money maybe you'll
make money i don't know i mean i don't
make money going to vegas maybe liv
berry our free previous guest or maria
konicova could make money in vegas but i
tend to lose it i think that like once
or twice i've had a trip to vegas and
i've made enough money playing poker to
pay for the hotel room there i don't
think i've ever made enough to play for
the hotel room and for the dinners
uh with jennifer and i going to vegas
good eating out is is a huge reason why
we go like we can sort of kick back
during the day relax
you can go to the pool or sit and read a
book or whatever or just kick around um
and then have some of the world's best
food at night the aria is a great place
for food um but you know explore all the
different possibilities the mgm grand
across the street has a bunch of good
places it has the ateliers
which is a wonderful
semi-casual
version of oat cuisine there
the bellagio and caesar's palace have
amazing high-end restaurants like
picasso and geese avoir but there's also
a lot more non-high-end restaurants that
are really excellent roy choi who is the
chef who is in charge of the koji
barbecue taco truck here in la
opened um a vegas restaurant called best
friend which i highly recommend it's in
the park mgm
um a weird wonderful
collection of you know korean slash
italian slash barbecue food that that
will leave you smiling for sure
the cosmopolitan also has a lot of fun
little restaurants there's a jose andres
spanish restaurant that is really really
good it's that it just goes on there's
just so many good places to eat
also window shopping or real shopping if
you're into that
but arya has some shops it's not great
aria i think made a terrible um mistake
that whole city center complex that aria
is part of
um rather than having interesting
shopping they just built like a high-end
mall the crystals mall right in the
middle of the of the complex and it has
you know
prada and gucci and whatever if that's
what you're into but you can get those
other places um
places like the forum shops at caesars
palace have quirky little shops that are
not located anywhere else so i would
give that
a look if you want for playing poker you
know i haven't played poker in vegas in
quite a long time because it's been a
pandemic um the aria has a great poker
room it's a little bit high end so uh
you know be ready for that um mgm grand
is a slightly lower end so a little bit
cheaper a little bit weaker competition
if you want to try that also it's still
very luxurious environment overall and
then
the bellagio is always fun to go to just
so you can say you went to the bellagio
um i actually tend to do way better in
the tournaments they have like daily
tournaments at almost every poker room
in vegas
uh 100 bucks 150 bucks you enter
maybe 30 or 40 people have entered that
kind of thing you know you start in the
morning and in the evening one day uh
but you can also just play um ongoing
ring games at a table any time so it's a
lot of fun you meet crazy people you
meet a whole wide variety of people
you're playing poker and the person on
one side of you is you know wearing
shorts and a t-shirt and the other one
is wearing a tuxedo on the other side of
you and
great stories bouncing back and forth
between all these people coming in from
all over the world to play poker in
vegas so i hope you have a good time
emmitt francis says do you have any
advice for a phd student me
working on putting together some
disparate pieces of work into a
dissertation my temptation is to spend
time working on telling a coherent story
through the dissertation
but my impression is that not many folks
read the dissertation itself and i
should perhaps focus more on getting at
least some of my unpublished research
submitted to a journal before i graduate
thoughts
so i think that this might be one of
those things that depends wildly on what
exact subfield you're in
so in theoretical high energy physics
it's a very simple thing no don't spend
any time whatsoever telling a coherent
story
most places like at caltech for example
or at harvard where i was
you just staple together your papers
write an introduction
and
whether or not you want to spend a lot
of time with the introduction
that's up to you it doesn't matter if
your papers are co-authored with other
people as long as you just are honest
about you know who the co-authors are
were and give them credit and as long as
a substantial amount of the work was
done by you
they are totally acceptable um for
chapters in a thesis i've had students
who've collaborated with me on papers
more than one student and you know a
single paper appeared in more than one
phd thesis defense that's a chapter as
well again as long as you're honest
about what you did there and really
contributed to it um and i know i get
where you're where you're coming from
because a lot of people
you know the pg thesis is a big thing
okay like don't i think a lot of people
make the mistake of
by the time they're defending their
thesis or whatever it's anticlimactic
because there's a lot of pressure to get
a postdoc job to figure out the rest of
your life and things like that and if
your advisor is even halfway competent
you should not get to the point of
defending your thesis without it being a
foregone conclusion that you will pass
it should not be a stressful thing it is
it can be stressful but it shouldn't be
um and therefore for a lot of people
they're like okay they're ready to move
on and they're like just give me the
degree and i move on whereas i think
it's a big deal you worked hard for
years to get to this point and i'm a big
believer in you know pomp and ceremony
about these things that's why
i have i recently posted on twitter the
updated collection of champagne bottles
in my office uh one for each successful
phd thesis defense whenever one of my
students defends a phd thesis i buy two
bottles of champagne one goes to me one
goes to them to do with what we want we
drink it but then we store the bottle or
not as we choose um
so i'm a big believer in
caring about the phd thesis and its
defense but as a
as a text
as a collection of words and thoughts uh
yeah almost no one's going to read it
right especially if it's like in
theoretical high energy theory it's it's
a collection of papers
you could write an introduction that is
pedagogical and and has some value added
but you know rewriting the chapters so
they fit together to tell a story for
something that no one will ever read is
probably not the best use of your time
if you could get some of the unpublished
research submitted to a journal that
would be much more useful yes i agree on
that on the other hand there are other
subfields that think about it very
differently in different ways when i was
at chicago they had what i thought was a
very weird uh
rule which is that
phd students you know you you acted like
a regular phd student you wrote a bunch
of papers collaborated with your advisor
with other students with whoever but
then your thesis
was one hefty single author paper
um you had to write a paper and it had
to be submitted to a journal and either
published or on the road to being
published and that was your phd thesis
i thought it's a dumb rule i get it i
get why they want to do it because
you're supposed to show that you can do
it all by yourself
good
um but it's just not natural like i
think that a lot of things at chicago
were rules or even grad student grad
schools more
broadly
there are a lot of rules that people
come up with
uh hurdles you have to leap to
successfully get through this process
that are not necessarily aimed at making
you the best researcher you can be
a real researcher will write a single
author paper when they have a good idea
by themselves and have the wherewithal
to write it up themselves that's fine
but sometimes that doesn't happen if i
have a good idea and i need someone to
do some 3d numerical simulation
i'm not going to either not do it or
try to teach myself 3d numerical
simulations i'm going to go to a friend
who can do 3d numerical simulations and
we're going to collaborate and that's
the natural thing to do and i think it's
weird to sort of
penalize that in in some way um anyway
so that's a different
way of doing it and my point is just
that different places different
subfields have different ways of doing
it so you should really ask this
question of people who are exactly
within
your subspecialty just so i'm not
leading you the wrong way
john smith says how do you keep yourself
in good physical shape uh well a
question is being begged here
whether or not i do keep myself
in good physical shape uh but the but to
be honest i actually for the past few
years have been a member of the gym and
signed up for personal training classes
at the gym
and the reason i do that is because
otherwise i just don't work out i'm a
big believer in
working out exercising trying to stay
relatively fit not like athlete level
toned or anything like that but moving
like i have a job that basically
involves sitting in front of a computer
screen all day right or sitting in front
of a piece of paper although these days
i use my ipad so sitting in front of an
ipad which is not any much better a lot
of sitting is involved in my job even
right now when i'm podcasting i'm still
sitting talking to you um so getting out
and and moving around is is i think
something i think crucially important
and
even though the personal trainer is good
because they you know make sure i'm
doing exercises correctly and the right
collection of them the single biggest
thing is that it's an appointment and i
gotta go right i can't just say yeah i
don't feel like it today
um and i i completely understand this is
only because i'm at a point in my life
now where i can afford something like
that
it gets me out of the house it's worth
the money i think right um and it
definitely does make a difference since
i've started doing it you know jennifer
who is a is a
workout demon you know she's naturally
like she works out every day and has for
many years she has a black belt and jiu
jitsu
and bless her heart she
never
sort of nudged me to do it even though
when she first met me i was not working
out very much at all when i was like a
student when i was in grad school or
postdoc i would like play basketball all
the time and run around and do things
and then you kind of like get a little
sluggy after that
but even though she was completely
silent about the matter her good example
nudged me to doing something about it
and getting out there and going to the
gym so that's what i try to do
okay i'm gonna group two questions
together one is from andre dinu who says
you mentioned in the past that hilbert
space
which for those non-experts out there
the space of all possible quantum
mechanical wave functions hilbert's
space could be either infinite
dimensional or could have a finite
number of dimensions but in the latter
case the number of dimensions could be
at least 10 to the 10 to 120.
how was this number estimated is it
approximately three times n where n is
the number of elementary particles in
the visible universe
something like that the other question
is cubit who says i often think about
what kind of mathematical object the
wave function of the universe really is
to keep things simple i like to think
about it in the position representation
my first guess is that the wave function
is then a function of n location vectors
where n is the number of elementary
particles in the universe however i'm
not sure how this picture can handle the
creation annihilation of elementary
particles should i think about this like
the wave function gets or loses some of
its arguments
during the time evolution not sure how
the hamiltonian of the universe could
achieve such changes to the wave
function
so these are not exactly the same
question certainly not the same question
but they're related to this issue of
hilbert space and the number of
dimensions of hilbert space and what the
wave function really is uh let me say
one thing which i usually resist trying
to say but it still remains true which
is that i wrote a book about this
something deeply hidden and if you're
really interested if you're interested
enough to ask these kinds of questions
you know you should read the book
because i do answer these questions in
the book now admittedly
uh i own books and have even read books
and nevertheless do not understand or
remember everything in them so if you've
if you've read the book and still have
questions that's completely cool but
you'll get a much clearer picture not
just of the answer to an individual
question but of how everything fits
together if you check out the book okay
more than i can say in an ama answer so
the point is um when you start with a
quantum mechanical system thought about
as some collection of particles
as soon as you just say well i have a
particle in space okay so the particle
can take on any location in ordinary
classical mechanics space is continuous
the particle can be anywhere
the hilbert space that you get from that
even from one particle is infinite
dimensional
because you can the dimensions out the
dimensionality of hilbert space is the
number of possible observational
outcomes when you measure
something about the particle so if you
measure the position of the particle and
you could get an infinite number of
different answers that's an infinite
dimensional hilbert space right there so
when you say that the universe might
have a finite dimensional hilbert space
you've already said
there is something that is not
just taking a bunch of particles and
quantizing it you're doing something
more elaborate now let me skip ahead a
little bit to qubit's question about
how particles could be created or
destroyed
uh yeah if you have a theory of n
particles in quantum mechanics or for
that matter in classical mechanics and
that's what your theory is of then in
classical mechanics you would have a
phase space in quantum mechanics you
have a hilbert space and there's no way
for the number of particles to change
this is why you invent field theory this
is exactly the reason
you could start with field theory and
find out that it looks like particles
you can also
start with particles and say rather than
having n particles
my configuration quantum mechanically is
a superposition of
zero particles one particle two particle
three particles and there can be
transitions between them okay but
they're all there they're all there in
the possible places in hilbert space so
you have to add up all those things and
what you find mathematically is that
it's completely equivalent to a quantum
field theory even if you just start with
particles a many-body quantum system as
they call it is equivalent to a quantum
field theory
and it's the quantum field theory that
lets you talk about transitions between
different numbers of particles creation
annihilation the part the wave the
quantum field is waving or it's not so
it's very easy to understand creation
annihilation of particles in the field
theory perspective the hilbert space
never changes size in fact it's always
infinite dimensional so it becomes a
little bit less puzzling but it doesn't
even sort of get a bigger infinity or a
smaller infinity it just always includes
the possibility of zero particles one
particle two particle up to billions of
particles
baked in from the start into hilbert's
space
parenthetically by the way the number of
observable of particles in the
observable universe is something like 10
to the 88th so it is not
10 to 120 it's certainly not 10 to the
10 to 120. uh so back to andre's
question then where does this finite but
big number come from if it has nothing
to do with the number of particles in
the universe the answer is gravity
remember that stephen hawking gave us a
formula for the entropy of a black hole
namely the entropy is the area of its
event horizon divided by four in plonk
units
and we think that not only
is that entropy a reflection of the
entanglement between things inside
degrees of freedom inside the black hole
and outside but we also think that the
black hole is a maximum entropy state
for a fixed volume of space time there
is no configuration that is higher
entropy than a black hole
and what that means is
the fact that the entanglement entropy
of the black hole is finite indicates
there's a finite dimensional hilbert
space
of things that can go on inside the
black hole and if you go through the
math it turns out to be
e to the entropy or 10 to the entropy
the entropy is so big it doesn't matter
whether you're raising it to the power
of e or 10 honestly
and something very similar to that you
say well we don't live in a black hole
in the universe that's true but we live
in a universe that is approaching the
sitter space the center space is an
accelerating universe with the cosmos
constant as we've already talked about
and decider space is surrounded by a
horizon and it has an entropy and the
formula is the same the formula is the
area of the event horizon divided by
four in plank units so it just turns out
that if you run the numbers for our
actual universe
our actual universe with a cosmological
constant if that's the thing that is
causing the universe to accelerate we'll
approach a dissider phase with a horizon
surrounding us the horizon is the place
past which once a galaxy or something
like that leaves we can never
communicate it with it ever again space
is expanding too fast for us to ever
catch up to it so there's a horizon
around us and its area is roughly 10 to
120. so the entropy associated with that
is 10 120 the hilbert space is 10 to the
10 to 120 dimensional it's a big number
but notice it has nothing to do with the
number of particles it's just a feature
of space-time itself which kind of makes
sense
in the future all the particles will
more or less scatter to the four winds
right that's what happens as
the universe expands in fact i've told
the story before but for years
i was convinced or at least speculated
that there was a family resemblance
between the
expansion of the universe and something
called the cosmic no-hair theorem which
uh bob wald proved in the 80s a theorem
that says if you have a positive
cosmological constant you not only does
the universe expand forever but it
always smooths out to become decider
space
that always reminded me of the second
law of thermodynamics or of the process
of equilibration in thermodynamics where
entropy increases
until you get to the equilibrium point
and then you just stay there forever
it's equilibrated so finally aiden
chapman davis and i proved a theorem
under certain assumptions which is
necessary to do theorems
we proved a theorem that says literally
that the second law of thermodynamics is
the cosmic no-hair theorem that if you
assume you have a gravitational system
whose entropy is proportional to the
area of the event horizon has a finite
upper bound
you will evolve to decider space even
without using einstein's equation so
that was a very cool little result
linus larabee asks a priority question
remember for those of you who are new
the priority questions if you're a
patreon supporter and ask an ama
question you know i can't always answer
all of them so the the loophole is that
every user
every supporter gets once in their life
the ability to ask a priority question
which i will
answer i don't necessarily guarantee i
will answer it to your satisfaction but
i will answer it up here so linus asks
on a one one-to-five scale how annoying
are patrons who can't seem to follow
simple directions
regarding questions on amas
um
i i know you're coming from because i do
have every single time i post the ama
there are instructions directions on you
know uh yeses and things to do and
things not to do
yeses and no's for asking ama questions
and every time people ignore them but
actually you know not that much most
people follow them and there are a lot
of directions there are a lot of little
rules because we've been doing this for
a while now we know our way around we
know what the failure modes are
so honestly it doesn't bother me that
much it's easy enough for me to ignore
the people who
do not follow the directions
most common directions are keep your
questions short most most common
directions that are ignored
are keep your questions short don't ask
me to read papers or videos or anything
like that i don't like special
relativity puzzles and everyone only
gets one question per ama those are the
main as far as i can recall right now
those are the main uh instructions every
one of them gets violated every month
that's okay as i
i'm more annoyed by other things in the
world honestly right now
lothian 53 says
a many worlds question this is probably
too basic for this group but how does
many worlds explain the interference
pattern observed with the double slit
experiment it would seem that the
particles are interfering with the other
worlds but i thought that once split
there was no way that one world would
affect any others
well i mean yes and no
i would not say that the particles are
interfering with other worlds but other
people would say differently i think i'm
not 100 sure about this but i think that
david deutsch would say oh yeah they're
definitely interact uh interfering with
other worlds but the point is that there
is a
set of worlds
well what can i say there's a wave
function and it evolves according to
schroedinger's equation that's what
really happens okay
everything else is commentary but the
commentary is important and in the
commentary we can talk about the world
having branched by decoherence or not
yet having branched if the world has not
yet branched then you can talk about it
either as just one world and that's what
i would honestly
prefer to do and in that world there are
wave functions for the different
particles and things like that or even
better there's one wave function in that
world for all the particles all the
stuff
or you could sort of look into the
future and say you know
there's going to be branching so it's
almost like there's a whole bunch of
worlds that are already here but they're
all exactly the same they're all
identical so it's as if there's just one
world
and in that latter description you would
say that the particles passing through
the double slits are interacting or
interfering with uh particles from other
worlds but all the worlds are exactly
the same okay so it's not it's a weird
way of talking in in my perspective i
would just like to say
before there's any branching before this
decoherence and the wave function is
split there's one world and there's a
wave function and the wave function is a
wave and it interferes and that's it
that's all you need to say uh don't
think about particles think about the
fact that it's a wave it's the wave
function that is the real thing
okay i'm going to group two questions
together
vladimir bellic says imagine it's the
last day of your well-deserved vacation
and after a fun and relaxing afternoon
it would soon be time to enjoy a special
dinner with your wife for this occasion
a magical personal chef is at your
service
he can prepare any meal from your memory
but not only that he can pick any
location on earth for this dinner and
he'll teleport both of you there set the
table and shield you from any
environmental effects if need be what
location do you choose and what do you
order
and then trevor trevor brittnell says
you recently mentioned that your
favorite restaurant is alinea
have you been to any other three
michelin star restaurants or restaurants
on the world's 50 best restaurants lists
and how do they compare
um see let me answer the second one
first because it will illuminate the
first one uh the linea is my favorite
restaurant olinia is a three michelin
star restaurant in chicago that i've
been to a few times
um and i have been actually two other
three michelin star restaurants i'm not
even gonna be able to remember
you know like i know i've been there but
i can't remember which ones are one star
and two-star and three-star or whatever
uh but some fancy restaurants i've been
to are uh the french laundry famous one
uh in northern california
vegas has several i've already mentioned
earlier guise of war and joel robuschon
and picasso all have multiple michelin
stars
dinner
in london is one of our favorite
restaurants uh dinner is the second best
restaurant uh by chef heston blumenthal
his best restaurant is the fat duck
which i have not been to fat duck is up
there in your list of uh possibly best
restaurants in the world um
several restaurants in new york
daniel and eleven madison park uh and a
couple of restaurants in paris pierre
garnier um another jewelry bouchon a
couple in copenhagen i think kong hans
kelder was a maybe three michelin stars
anyway
a bunch i'm old i've been around i've
traveled a lot and i like eating so i
like would rather spend my money on
these restaurants than many other ways
that i could spend money
save your save your pennies actually
i've never made this point but you know
um people think about like
spending a huge amount of money at for a
fancy dinner
because like if you if
probably the upper limit would be
at one of these restaurants i mean
there's no upper limit because you can
spend it on wine right you get a bottle
of wine for ten thousand dollars and
there you go
but if you just get like a reasonable
bottle of wine
and but otherwise you know do the full
tasting menu extravaganza you should
probably plan that per person you're
spending a few hundred dollars maybe up
to 500
at a restaurant like this
and that seems like just a crazy amount
of money right 500 per person for a meal
but the way i think about it is it's a
lot cheaper than uh going to disneyland
for several days right um
it's
the comparison i use maybe i have said
this
out loud before but you know i'm never
going to
stay overnight in the world's fanciest
hotel room or drive the world's fanciest
car or live in the world's fanciest
house or whatever but these
these meals at fancy restaurants are as
good arguably the best meals you can get
in the world like no matter how rich you
are it's just as good as a meal that
jeff bezos could possibly eat right
and it's 500 bucks
which is again you know a vacation right
um so for me that's well worth that
particular way of budgeting your your
pleasure dollars um i'm a foodie in that
sense anyway
anyway um to answer your question trevor
uh i think lydia's at the top of that
list you know some of the meals i've had
there have been better than others um
but they've there's never been a dud
they've all been amazing it's it's a
linear for those of you who don't know
is one of these
they use the phrase molecular gastronomy
although i think that the chef grant
decketts uh isn't a big fan of the term
by the way i did you know i made an
effort to get grant accounts on the
podcast uh and i think i came close we
were
tweeting back and forth but it never it
never turned out but uh chef hacketts if
you're listening to this we'd love to
have you on mindscape podcast um
it's many small courses right it's not
like a three-course meal it's like a
20-course meal or a 15-course meal but
the courses are very small and they're
spread over three hours or whatever um
but in every
course is the reason why eleni is great
is because
i've been to
bad molecular gastronomy restaurants
where you know they're trying too hard
to be weird you know there was one
restaurant where you know they they
bring a plate covered to your
table and then with a flourish they open
the plate and there's a cell phone
on the plate and then the cell phone
rings and says come downstairs and you
go downstairs and you pick up your dish
for that particular course and then i'm
like oh yeah this is kind of annoying
and there's like foams and things like
that that sometimes you know what why is
it like this
um but olinium manages to hit that sweet
spot where every
meal every course is endlessly inventive
and different
but just tastes really really good i
mean that's the thing like they have
this real expertise at getting tastes
together in ways that you wouldn't have
guessed and textures and timings and and
odors and sounds and the whole bit um
it's the full experience that i really
really enjoy very very well there
uh so that's yeah still my favorite
restaurant compared to all those i was a
little bit disappointed with the french
laundry uh to be honest i think the
french laundry is phoning it in a little
bit because i know that grant akitz has
said that you know if he gets a last
meal he would like it to be the french
laundry and so i really wanted to go
there to see what the fuss was about i
would say lenny is way better so to
vladimir's question that's what i would
want
i want grant atkids to be my magical
chef who prepares me a meal the point is
that when you go one of these really
good restaurants not only is it really
good but you could never guess ahead of
time what's coming next you know the
things they do with food are endlessly
inventive so
i mean i totally sympathize if someone
says you know i want a good medium rare
steak or you know i want a good
vegetarian souffle or whatever it is you
want if you have a favorite thing and
you want to get that i get that but i
would put myself in the hands of someone
who is much more creative and
knowledgeable about food than i am and
let them do it um as to where i thought
about that i really don't know that's a
good question you know like could be
somewhere weird the top of mount everest
because you specified that uh there's a
shield from any environmental effects or
under the sea would also be a lot of fun
but i haven't really scouted these
locations so i couldn't tell you for
sure
ted anderson says physicists assume that
fundamental particles of the same type
are identical how do we how well do we
know that for example how much variation
in the mass of the electron would there
have to be before it would upset current
theories or we could detect it with
measurements
so if you accept the basic framework of
current theories um the theory itself is
pretty clear that all electrons have
exactly the same mass it is not an
assumption
i mean phys it's always a little bit
wrong when you say like physicists
assume this that's just not quite
getting
your finger on the way physicists work
physicists uh hypothesize things you
know they invent a theory and according
to theory something is true but they're
open to the possibility that it's not
true you know
physicists assume lorenzen variants but
my first ever published paper was on
violating the rents and variants and it
became very popular because if you can
figure out a way to test deviations from
those hypotheses people are very happy
that's what they like to do
variations of masses of particles
certainly have been tested i really
don't know how accurately to be honest
but what i wanted to emphasize was
as i just said a little bit ago
in modern physics it's a field right
there's an electron field that vibrates
and that we see it as electron particles
so this is why uh the masses of all
electrons are exactly the same because
they're vibrations in exactly the same
field so this was you know there's this
story that john wheeler was puzzled why
electrons all have the same charge in
the same mass and he had this theory oh
when he realizes that an electron could
be thought of going backward in time as
a positron that maybe there's only one
electron people are very excited by this
but that's not correct he was not right
you have to yet understand we've made
progress since then we know why all the
electrons have the same mass in charge
because their vibrations in the same
field
we could definitely try to test it and
i'm sure we have but i have no idea what
the actual numerical limits are
michael shillingford asks a priority
question
in the episode with jody azuni it said
that his object projectivism which is
tantamount to ontological nihilism is
bumping it up against your work in
quantum mechanics but how so the
genetian ontology you contrasted with is
obviously much more permissive
is your physics research pulling toward
the two poles of either eliminativism or
permissivism
um
i'll apologize i forget exactly what was
said um
what i can think of that i might have
been getting at is
the overall question of nominalism
is something that has come up
in uh my recent thinking about the
foundations of quantum mechanics and the
this is par in part again i forget if
i've mentioned this who knows what i've
done and what i've not done um on the
podcast but
uh justin clark doane who is one of our
previous guests who writes about the
philosophy of math as well as the moral
philosophy
he and i had a podcast conversation we
were also talking about mathematical
realism etc and he has a set of
arguments for mathematical realism and
in his mind a good physicist is just
going to be forced to be a mathematical
realist
because you need a lot of math to do
physics that's a simple naive way of
saying it but also because once you have
enough math
once you have sufficiently powerful
mathematical formalisms mathematical
axiomatic systems
then as girdle showed us
those systems can make statements about
their own consistency
and if you want
uh your physical theory to be consistent
which presumably you do presumably you
want the physical world to be consistent
with itself i'm not even sure how you
could not have that
then he says you sort of need to believe
in the realism of that those
mathematical results okay you can't
uh prove the consistency of the theory
within itself you just have to assume it
and that's tantamount to mathematical
realism
and you know i kind of i'm i'm open to
that possibility i'm not an expert
in these mathematical logic foundations
of mathematics questions but it rubs me
the wrong way a little bit i want to
think that the reality is the physical
world and mathematics is not part of
that reality it's a separate thing it's
the way we talk about the physical world
so
that has led me to ask myself
is it possible to invent or to
contemplate theories of physics
that don't need sufficiently strong
mathematics
that they can even talk about their own
consistency they can just be consistent
or even
even better
just the right amount of power that they
can prove their own consistency there
are versions of
mathematical axiomatic systems that can
do that
uh and and so that's what i'm thinking
about now and i think the answer is yes
but again i'm not an expert on it so i'm
not very good at it so i can't tell you
quite the answers but i'm supposed to be
writing a paper for um for a symposium
that justin is organizing
so we'll see how that goes and i will
let you know um so i don't think that i
need so so that it would be compatible
with the kind of
um
nominalism about math right
nominalism about
form about abstract objects you don't
need to uh imagine that numbers are just
as real as electrons are under that
construal
now i think that's a little bit separate
in in my view from the question of
levels of reality and emergent reality
like i can i can think that the so i i
differ from jody about the reality of
microsoft for example i think that
microsoft is real i think it is part of
a level of description of the world it
is not the most fundamental level but
it's as real as consciousness and
then tables and chairs are okay
um again not an expert in this but
that's how i would put it so i i think
you can be a realist about higher levels
of reality which is this genetician
kind of sense of real patterns and
nevertheless not necessarily realistic
about abstract mathematical objects
chris chotard says i'm struggling with
two different interpretations of the cmb
anisotropy the first one says that
temperature fluctuations reflect the
quantum fluctuations of the matter in
its very early form
the second one says they are due to the
gravitational lensing of all the matter
the radiation has met during its journey
to us could it be both uh so no it
cannot be the second one the cmb
fluctuations are absolutely not due to
gravitational lensing there is an effect
of gravitational lensing that
contributes to
the anisotropics of the cmb but it's
generally a very small amount and it
only shows up on relatively small
angular scales the vast majority of what
you see when you look at cnb and
isotropes is not from gravitational
lensing what it's from is
density fluctuations of the primordial
plasma just before recombination just
before
the electrons and the protons teamed up
to make hydrogen now we speculate
that those density fluctuations
might be due to quantum fluctuations in
the very very very early universe but
that's just a speculation we don't know
that what we know with with a high
degree of confidence is that the
temperature fluctuations 380 000 years
after the big bang that we see in the
cmb
are from density fluctuations in the
plasma at that time
not
because of gravitational lensing since
then
francis day asks a priority question
often i hear you and your guest
scientists use a phrase something like
i've thought a lot about this
in terms of thinking about a physics
problem what is your process
i would guess it involves talking to
colleagues reading papers maybe sitting
and thinking uh yeah you you've guessed
exactly correctly it involves all of
those things uh in fact
sitting and thinking is the most
important one i mean talking to
colleagues and reading papers is
important
but if you're making progress on
something that um
you know is is new and interesting at a
research level you're doing a lot of
lonely sitting and thinking and then
hopefully it works and you get to
excitedly talk to your uh colleagues
later
so you know
again i'm always reluctant to
label anything that i do as a process
in any formal sense because i just do
whatever works in the moment and it's
not necessarily very formalized so
different
ideas different things you've thought a
lot about
um come in different ways come from
different places you know some of them
are
kind of uh programmatic so you say like
hmm i would like to understand this and
i think i see how to do it let's sit and
do it so in other words sometimes you
come up with a topic for a research
project where just as soon as you come
up with the topic it's pretty clear what
you got to do to turn that idea into a
paper you know
let me give you an example just randomly
off the top of my head i wrote a paper
about
dark matter several years ago
here was the puzzle um
there's
there are some weak astrophysical hints
we talked a little bit about this in the
podcast with priya natarajan that
there's some weak astrophysical hints
that non-interacting dark matter isn't
quite up to the task right ordinary cold
dark matter models the dark matter
doesn't interact with itself at all it
just sort of moves under the force of
gravity it's it's weakly interacting so
and that's so weak that it doesn't
matter
so some people have said well what if
it's strongly interacting then we can
explain some of these astrophysical
anomalies and that may or may not be
true honestly i don't know that's a hard
astrophysics problem but it's intriguing
right from the particle physics point of
view because here is the problem with
that
you can
make the particles interact you can just
say well yeah they bump into each other
or they annihilate or whatever but
there's a relationship between the
interaction strength and the abundance
of the particles when the particles
interact strongly they tend to
annihilate away in the early universe
that's why weakly interacting particles
are so interesting as dark matter
candidates because the weak interactions
of particle physics give you roughly the
right
annihilation rate to give you the right
abundance of dark matter to explain the
observations so if you just say well i
want the dark matter to be strongly
interacting you have an extra puzzle
about why there is the right amount of
dark matter in the current universe
so i had an idea which is you know we
have the higgs mechanism in ordinary
standard model particle physics where
there's a phase transition and before
the phase transition particles like the
electron and the quarks were bassless
and afterward they're massive because
the higgs field changes its value and
that changes the masses of these
particles so what if you did something
like that but did it with
the interaction strength of the
particles rather than their mass have a
phase transition to change the
interaction strength of the particles so
they were weakly interacting in the
early universe they give you the right
relic abundance phase transition happens
and now they're strongly interacting in
some way and that has astrophysically
interesting results so that was the idea
that's something you can come up with
walking to work feeding the cats taking
a shower or whatever
and the work that you need to do
to turn that into a paper in that case
is pretty straightforward you just okay
start writing down models here's a an
action a lagrangian you know let's
figure out what the particles could be
how they interact with each other
calculate some interaction rates the
relic abundance blah blah blah
figure out uh how big the effects can be
without running into other limits from
all these other experiments we've done
is a pretty straightforward set of
things to do when you set about doing it
other projects
all you start with really is a vague
hope you know you say like
okay uh we've already said that the
hilbert's base of the universe is about
10 to the 10 to 120 dimensional right
that we said that earlier in the podcast
but the quantum field theory hilbert
space is infinite dimensional so
how do you reconcile that where do the
extra dimensions of hilbert space that
you thought you had in quantum field
theory where do they go
that's a very open-ended question i
bring this up because some students and
i spent a year thinking about it and
didn't get anywhere we did not publish
anything about it other people have
talked about similar things but uh you
know the structure of hilbert space in a
quantum gravity model or something like
that is a vague enough question that you
don't exactly know what to do so you do
exactly what you said you talk to
colleagues you read papers you sit and
you think and you scribble down some
equations
whatever gets you in the right direction
okay i'm going to
group together two questions uh one is
from josh powers suppose i look into the
sky and see the light from alpha
centauri showing that it existed four
years in my past then i wait five years
and see it again indicating that it
still still exists
this implies that it like me has existed
continuously for those five years and it
stands to reason
that at any point in my subjective time
something was also happening at alpha
centauri therefore
it seems like we do share a common
present even if we can't communicate to
determine what events are simultaneous
this can seems to contradict the idea
that there is no universal present what
am i missing
and then david mcburney says
in the biggest ideas uh video on
entanglement you wrote the wave function
for the universe with n particles as psi
of x1 x2 xn and time we often hear from
relativity that statements like what is
happening right now in alpha centauri
are not sensible because time is
relative there's no such thing as now if
some of the n particles are on earth and
some are in alpha centauri and the
location of the particles evolves per
the schrodinger equation that seems like
there is some preferred time is this
another incompatibility of quantum
mechanics and relativity
so uh in both cases you know everything
is fine don't worry
there's no universal present and there's
no necessary incompatibility with
quantum mechanics and relativity um i
guess to get david's the second question
first once again
um
when you write the wave function the
universe for particles right x1 x2 x3
probably you're working in the
non-relativistic approximation for one
thing right because if you were
relativistic you probably should be
doing quantum field theory but that's
just a little aside the more important
thing is what you've done in either case
is chosen a frame chosen a set of
coordinates to extend across the
universe
relativity doesn't say you're not
allowed to extend coordinates over the
universe it says that there are many
ways of extending coordinates over the
universe and they're all equally good
so when i pick a reference frame when i
let's say i'm going to pick my reference
frame the one that is at rest with
respect to what i am doing right now
as long as space time is not very curved
if it's almost special relativity i can
extend
a reference frame so i can just go you
know in in my mind in a thought
experiment i can extend lines in a
space-like direction
at the moment i am right now and call
that the same time as i am right now
different observers moving at different
rates would do that differently
so they would define now differently
but any one of them could write down a
wave function psi of x1 x2 xn and their
time coordinate and there would be a
schrodinger equation that told you how
it evolved and the schrodinger equations
would look a little bit different
because they would be lorenz
transformations of each other they'd be
transformations from one term from one
time coordinate to another but they're
all equally good they're all allowed
so
it's not that there's some preferred
times there's many allowed times and
that's one of them
to josh's uh question it's it's sort of
the same thing but kind of from the
opposite point of view when when you say
i see the light from alpha centauri
showing that it existed four years in my
past that's already not quite right
it's four years in your past in a
certain reference frame namely the
reference frame in which you and alpha
centauri are more or less stationary
right you and alpha centauri
are
essentially moving at the same speed
compared to the speed of light your
relative velocity is very small so there
is a reference frame that is has both
you and that other star more or less at
rest it's in that reference frame
that alpha the light you are seeing from
alpha centauri is four years in your
past if you were moving
right past the same point in space so
still four light years away uh from
alpha centauri but you were moving sorry
i shouldn't say that you're moving the
same point in space uh but you're moving
at
0.9999 the speed of light in the
direction of alpha centauri then the
light you receive now from alpha
centauri wasn't four years in the past
it was much less than four years in the
past because you're going to get there
right and from a point of view from your
point of view it will take you much less
than four years to get there and the
limit as you go at the speed of light it
takes you zero years to get there from
your point of view
so when you say that uh you make a
series of
observations and you see that alpha
centauri is there now and it's there
five years from now and for all that
matter you could see it the whole time
you're still
making an arbitrary choice of reference
frame in which to do that so that
that reference frame is perfectly usable
you're allowed to talk about what
happens in that reference frame you're
just not allowed to uh treat it as
somehow special or universal
okay jimmy summer has a priority
question
i've listened
to your colloquia on quantum space time
at least the one that's available on
youtube i absolutely love the idea of
your program i was just curious though
where are we with emergent space time in
general what are the most recent
advancements and what still seems
still needs to be worked out and if it
all works out will this essentially
resolve the general relativity quantum
mechanics reconciliation problem for
example what do you think happens to
black hole singularities in these
emergent space-time theories i know
we're still always from getting there
but you have any personal conjectures
um yeah i think that the specific ideas
that i've been working on with my
friends and colleagues uh are very very
young and primitive compared to other
more advanced research programs so
i think it's very promising i think that
you know we start from
a very simple set of assumptions about
how quantum gravity works the number of
dimensions in helper space things like
that
um but we give ourselves very little to
work with you know we don't even give
ourselves space
which everyone else does
so we have to build up a lot of things
and honestly we haven't even built up
light cones yet
it's kind of easy to see how they might
arise but we need to have a more
dynamical understanding we have kind of
kinematics more than dynamics right now
at the level that we're working at
and also all the really tangible
quantitative results that we have are in
the weak field limit where gravity is
not that strong so we're not thinking
about
black holes or horizons or anything like
that
so there's plenty to be done
establishing that you can get lorenzen
variants and for that matter um
you know we
it's been fun to be thinking about
gravity but you also have to think about
the rest of particle physics the rest of
the fields that we know and love the
gage theories and the fermions and the
higgs boson and all that stuff
um and i would like to get a better
handle on how best to describe those
things from a purely
starting with nothing but a quantum wave
function point of view from a vector in
hilbert space
so there's lots to do i would i would be
no i don't even want to guess about um
what is going to have to say about
singularities or anything like that
honestly the thing about singularities i
think is a low priority uh i would
rather understand black hole information
and um holography and things like that
from this point of view which i don't so
there you go but i think that it can be
done we'll just have to see
james dencaro says
i read somewhere that if dark matter is
a new subatomic particle it might be its
own antiparticle
and there are experiments looking for
the annihilation of pairs of dark matter
particles in the center of galaxies
how can a particle be its own
anti-particle what does it mean to be an
anti-particle
good so you've put your finger on
something that is a little sloppy in how
particle physicists talk uh to each
other as well as to the general public
which is they
they claim there's this thing called
particles and this thing called
anti-particles which is a bit of a cheat
the reality is some kinds of particles
have anti-particles and some don't like
there's no anti-photon for example
there's no anti-higgs boson there's just
the particles
some particles if a particle carries a
conserved charge other than mass that
that's a separate thing but if it
carries spin
uh or or no spin does not count sorry i
shouldn't count spin because you can
always convert that into other kinds of
angular momentum if it carries baryon
number or electric charge or something
like that then it will generally have an
anti-particle that has the opposite
amount of that conserved quantity so
charged particles are the most clear-cut
case where you have an electron it has a
negative charge
by the rules of quantum field theory and
relativity there has to be a positron
carrying a pos a positive charge
dark matter particles are neutral if
they were a charge they'd be visible
they would be like matter particles
visible matter particles
so
already there's at least the possibility
that they do not have antiparticles what
matters
as it were is not
particles and antiparticles this rule
that you know particles and
antiparticles can annihilate etc is just
a kind of sloppy rule of thumb what
matters are what interactions can happen
you know
and the point is that there are
interactions in theory of many kinds of
different dark matter particles where
two dark matter particles can
collide and convert into photons for
example
you don't need to use the phraseology of
particle antiparticle you just say the
two dark matter particles come together
and annihilate into photons that's all
you need and from that perspective it
just makes perfect sense there's mass
and energy in them there's no other
conserved quantities they can convert
that's a general quantum mechanical kind
of thing
okay matt from sweden says priority
question
if for the sake of clarity we define
global catastrophic risk as causing the
unexpected loss of at least 100 million
human lives from the 12-month period
what would in your estimation be the top
five global catastrophic risks within
the next 50 years
um
it's a perfectly good question i don't
you know i can give you an answer it's a
priority question i will do my best
i have no expertise in this we do have
an upcoming podcast we'll talk about
these questions a little bit uh in more
detail
but i have not sat down and studied the
relative rate of different global
catastrophic risks
um you know there's certainly a risk
from you know a huge asteroid hitting
the earth but i think that the
numbers there are very very tiny i would
say uh the two most obvious choices are
uh nuclear war one way or the other we
still have a lot of
operational nuclear weapons on this
planet and i know that we um depend on
how old you are but when i was a kid
growing up we were worried about nuclear
war
i was in ronald reagan's america and
nuclear war was something that was on
the agenda um but the weapons are still
there we've cut down the stockpiles but
the number of countries that have them
is only goes up with time it almost
never goes down so i that that risk has
not gone away that's a real one that we
should worry about more than we do to be
honest um and likewise the other obvious
one is uh bioterrorism
you know we're suffering through a
pandemic right now and i recently saw
that it is plausible
that if you don't just count the number
of people who died in hospitals and had
their deaths attributed to covid but if
instead you just
count the number of excess deaths that
we're going through now compared to what
we have before the pandemic you get a
number over 20 million excess deaths um
because of the kovid pandemic it's not
that far it's not an order of magnitude
away from 100 million right and the
thing about covet is it you know it's
especially nasty because you can get it
and not know
and yet be um
able to transmit it right you can be
infectious before you're symptomatic
and the good thing about covet is it's
not that deadly like you can you can get
it and you cannot die
uh it's easy to imagine a pandemic where
you get the virus you're not symptomatic
you can
transmit it to others and it kills you
once you do get the symptoms and that
would be absolutely devastating right
much more devastating than covet is so
that's another possibility if we don't
get better at this whole vaccine thing
both inventing them and convincing
people to take them
so if you want a top three um i will
always throw out my my favorite which is
solar flares i don't really necessarily
think it's in the top three but i don't
think we think about it enough because
uh if there's a one
one chance per thousand per year of a
gigantic solar flare that would
completely wipe out all the electronics
on earth uh we have no data
on that because a thousand years ago we
had no electronics
so
uh this is a plausible thing
it doesn't seem to be very likely to me
but it's completely conceivable
um that either solar flares or some
other kind of occasional
electronic huge event could cause a huge
devastation here on earth i don't know
if 100 million people would die but if
you just imagine no electricity
anywhere on earth for let's say a few
months
i can certainly imagine a lot of people
dying
um so anyway that's something to
not keep you up at night i hope we'll
we'll see
gonna group these next two together uh
chris a says i'm in conversation with a
christian who unlike me believes
miracles are intrinsically possible and
who demands less strict and supporting
evidence than i would for such claims
she's inclined to believe that a very
unusual event is miraculous whereas i
see it as surprising but not
supernatural at all
i realize that one is supposed to update
one's priors based on evidence but in
her case poor evidence is more
admissible than it would be with atheist
priors
can you suggest ways of discussing this
product productively in the context of
bayesian reasoning
and paul cousin says
imagine that you someday witness god
performing miracles
as a physicist you know better than
anyone why you should not expect the
laws of physics to be violated moreover
you know that the human brain is
sometimes subject to very weird failures
should bayesian thinking put you
sorry lead you to put higher credence on
a brain tissue brain issue in this
situation if so how can you trust your
reasoning
so both questions have to do with uh how
bayesians should be thinking about
the apparent appearance of miracles in
the world the first is someone thinks
that miracles are happening all the time
how do we use base against them the
second is what if the miracle actually
does happen how do we make sure that
baze doesn't mislead us
um you know so one question is your
priors this is always the question with
bayesian reasoning you come in to any
particular uh
experiment or situation
with some prior credences with some set
of beliefs about how likely different
things are
and i think you know if so for the first
question for chris's question if you
have someone who's already christian and
believes that miracles happen all the
time
then uh you're in a difficult position
it's true because you know anything that
happens you oh look they're miracle uh
it's very easy to see things like that
and i think that it's going to depend at
a practical level on how honest your
friend is about their reasoning
abilities here or the way that they
reason into it if if you want to use
your belief in miracles as the license
to believe whatever you want no one's
going to reason you out of that you're
just not being a very good bayesian but
if you are committed to being a good
bayesian but just someone who at the
moment believes in miracles what they
should be asking themselves is
if there weren't any miracles
how often would we be seeing these
things that we're seeing whether it's uh
i don't know people coming back from
being dead for a little while or the
virgin mary on a tortilla or whatever it
is right whatever the claim miracles is
someone gets healed
would you expect these things to be seen
just as frequently
or as frequently as you do actually see
them even if there were no actual
miracles in the world that's what you
have to establish because if that's true
if what you're seeing are things that
you would expect to see in a
miracle-free world then seeing the
miracles is not evidence
that the seeing the apparent miracles is
not evidence or violation of the laws of
physics and if that's not true if you
actually think that you know the rate at
which you would purportedly see these
things
uh is lower in your theory
purely physicalist theory than it is in
your experience then that legitimately
is evidence against the purely
physicalist theory and then you have to
cope with that of course in practice
it's very very hard to do these
calculations that's why you know
bayesian reasoning is
a good aspiration sometimes but you have
to when in putting it in practice
um we cut corners there's nothing else
that we can do what what is the
frequency at which you should expect to
see the virgin mary on a tortilla or
someone who has cancer suddenly go into
remission
i don't know i don't know in the absence
of god's intervention it's bound to
happen sometimes um but it's you know
very hard to calculate an actual number
but that's what you would try to tell
your friend of course then the other
question is their priors you know do
they
think that it is more likely in the
absence of any data that miracles are
happening all the time or more likely
that the laws of physics are being
obeyed some of us would say look a world
that just obeys the laws of physics all
the time is just simpler is this easier
to comprehend than a
a world in which the laws of physics are
usually obeyed but then occasionally
miraculously
violated and therefore you should put a
higher prior
on the physicalist world than the
miracle world but that's you know if
they don't want to accept that everyone
is excited uh everyone is entitled to
their own priors
likewise okay for paul's question um if
you are a good physicalist as well as a
good bayesian
what kind of miracles would it take you
uh would it take to convince you
otherwise because i am a big believer
that
a good bayesian should not rule out
supernatural possibilities
a priyari you know i never bought into
this very common claim
of methodological naturalism as part of
science that science has to assume
naturalism from the start i think that
science concludes naturalism because
it's the best fit to the data it doesn't
assume it from the start it's
methodologically empiricist
it
judges whether uh how to develop these
theories on the basis of data on the
basis of observations of the world
rather than on the basis of pure thought
and therefore if there are things that
are better explained by miracles
than by the laws of physics then that
should move your credences toward the
belief in miracles now as paul says it
could also be
a brain issue or something like that and
i think you should just be honest i
don't have numbers to give you
um but you you shouldn't you know it is
possible that it is a brain issue people
do hallucinate right or people uh
misremember or whatever those are all
absolutely possible
um in my current state of belief about
the world
if i saw something that looked
purportedly miraculous i would put a
very high credence on it being a mistake
on my part either a brain issue or a
hallucination or an optical illusion or
whatever but if it kept happening and if
it was you know reproducible or there's
good evidence for it then that would
move my credences in the other direction
there's no hard and fast cut off that's
the great thing about bayesian reasoning
you just accumulate evidence and keep
going you keep going where the evidence
is pointing you peter solfest says what
do you feel is the most effective way
for someone in your position to interact
with our democracy in order to promote
the policies you are in favor of eg
voting political conversations on your
podcast
talking directly with representatives
donating to interest groups etc
um yeah i think that it's going to be
different for different people i think
voting is true for everybody who can
vote right i'm a big believer in voting
it's not an obvious thing as we
discussed with herb gintus on the
podcast you know the rational case for
voting is a little tricky but i think it
i think it's makable depending on what
your goals are um
but then yeah beyond that uh you need to
do a little bit more you can do a little
bit more i don't mind people who don't
do a little bit more i do i would like
it if people voted um
i don't think talking directly with
representatives is usually helpful
compared to other things because
it's we're in a such a polarized
situation these days where the real
question is who are the representatives
you know are they in one party or the
other party like once you have that
um mostly the representatives will be
doing pretty predictable things now
there are obvious counter examples uh
fans of american politics will know that
in the u.s senate right now
which is nominally
50 50 but it's really
we have a democratic president vice
president so democrats get to win on the
tiebreakers
so democrats should have a majority in
the senate but we have two senators uh
who like to be ornery and contrarian and
not go along with the rest of the
democratic
um agenda so effectively you don't have
a majority in the senate it's very hard
to get things done so if i lived in
states where those
senators were representing me then i
might try my best to interact with them
directly
um otherwise yeah uh doing things that
can make people think or or move people
in the direction you think are moving
them whether it's having conversations
on the podcast or donating to interest
groups
you know as you know as many people know
i don't know depending on how long
you've been listening but
i am happy on the podcast to talk about
the ideas associated with politics
i am not happy to talk about um
political campaigns or things like that
i'm not stumping for individual
candidates and so forth you know i think
that even having politicians on the show
which i would do under the right
circumstances but it's not my first
choice because
they have a different agenda you know
they have an agenda of uh you know in
the in the cynical view getting elected
but even in the most idealistic view
they have the agenda of getting their uh
agenda passed right uh in
congress or whatever which is different
than my agenda which is understanding
how the world works so
um
if i'm talking about politics on the
podcast
it'll be talking about political ideas
with professors more often than it is
talking with actual politicians
and also you know i
if i'm influencing people
by talking on the podcast what i hope to
be influencing them to do is to think
for themselves um in ways that i think
are good ways to think the conclusions
people reach you know we'll see what
people should reach their own
conclusions but they should do it in
ways that are rational and hopefully
exhibit some compassion and empathy for
other people in society that's what i
would like to influence people to do
ingrid gorman says priority question
i don't understand how to reconcile a
theory of all time existing at once like
a loaf of bread and how we can also
understand emergence evolution for
example and other things that took time
to evolve
uh so one sub footnote here in this
question because i think this comes up
elsewhere in other questions we'll get
to the word emergence which i love using
i use it all the time
is it's not the perfect word for what
i'm describing when i talk about
emergence because the emergence i'm
talking about is not a process happening
over time
it's the simultaneous existence
of different descriptions of uh some
system and what it's doing like we
already said you could talk about the
gas in a box as a set of atoms or as a
fluid right that's emergence even though
it's not like the set of atoms are
turning into a fluid or anything like
that okay that was a footnote to
actually answer your question the trick
here
is that uh presumably what you're
talking about is the doctrine of
eternalism the blocked universe view of
reality which i happen to subscribe to
but the way that you phrase it is
a theory of all time existing at once
and the
worrisome part there is the phrase at
once because i would never say that
because you're that phrase at once
indicates a particular time right that's
what at once means once one time
but it kind of doesn't make sense to
imagine that all time exists at one time
because all time is a bunch of different
times the thing that an eternalist would
say is all time exists
all moments are equally real the current
moment you're in is real but future
moments are also real past moments are
also real they're not all real at the
same time or at once that would make no
sense but they're all real
and if it ever
seems weird to be thinking about that
just switch in your brain the question
from time to space right because in
relativity we're taught the time and
space are very very similar to each
other they're not exactly the same but
very similar and so
no one has a problem thinking that all
points in space exist right you're
located only one i mean if you coarse
grain so that uh you count as one point
in space and other places count as other
points okay um you're located somewhere
in space
that doesn't lead you to doubt the
existence of other points of space far
away uh they just all exist but you
happen to be located at one of them and
you count your position relative to
others that's how time works for an
eternalist
just like all the points in space are
real all the moments in time are real
you at one moment happen to exist in
that moment and
count your location in time relative to
other moments it all works in more or
less the same way that's i think the
best i can say
benjamin barbrell says
poetic naturalism recognizes the ability
to tell different kinds of true stories
about the world these stories use
different concepts applying different
domains of validity but need to be
consistent with each other the only way
i can imagine to ensure this consistency
would be a tree-like hierarchical
structure where the domain of validity
of stories closer to the trunk would
encompass those of emerging levels
higher in the branches
the existence of this structure is what
i always assumed reductionism was each
level can in principle reduce to a lower
wider level reading the big picture i
understand that what i describe is not
quite what you have in mind you don't
appeal to reductionism and it seems to
me the various discourses on the world
need not be organized in this fashion in
poetic naturalism
uh yes i think that you you got it
that's exactly right and part of it is
because i'm just trying to be careful
not to confuse what actually happens
with what
must necessarily happen
so in this picture
of different ways of talking about the
world
what i say is
there are domains of validity uh domains
of applicability i was told not to say
validity because philosophers use
validity
to refer to the validity of a logical
deductive argument okay so domains of
applicability um although validity
sounds better to me
so in the space of all possible things
that can happen in the world
different theories might accurately
describe what's going on in some
circumstances but not in others for
example once again if you go to the gas
in a box
since there are usually so many atoms
and molecules of gas in the box the
fluid description
also works to describe what happens in
that box but if you only had one
molecule in the box then there's no
fluid description that would work but
the atomic description still works
perfectly well right so the atomic
description is a little bit more
comprehensive it has a domain of
applicability that is a little bit
broader than the fluid description does
so if you imagine plotting you know some
venn diagram you would have the domain
of applicability of the atomic
description and then a subset of that
would be the domain of applicability of
the fluid description
it happens to be the case
that in many many
known and understood and familiar
examples of emergence
all of the theories
are entirely subsets of other theories
so in other words there is a hierarchy
there's like some big comprehensive
theory
and there's some emergent theory that is
a subset of that and a subsequent
immersion theory it is a subset of that
and so forth and the usual story is
something like physics chemistry biology
psychology sociology or whatever right
those are all
in those are all individual theories
that work under different circumstances
that are supposed to be consistent with
each other but something like sociology
has a much smaller domain of
applicability than
particle physics does domain of
applicability doesn't mean it's the best
way to look at it it makes no sense to
describe human beings using particle
physics but you don't want your human
beings to be incompatible with particle
physics either you want them to obey
those rules okay
having said all that
and i think that's what benjamin's guess
or original thought was but having said
all that this fact that higher level
theories or what we call higher level
theories fit inside the domains of
applicability of lower level theories
is in no sense necessary you know in the
space of how we could possibly imagine
knowledge being organized it's very easy
to imagine
you know two completely non-intersecting
domains of applicability or two
domains of applicability of different
theories that intersect without one
being a subset of the other right some
overlap but incomplete overlap
and i think
that those kinds of possibilities might
even be relevant for questions of things
like strong emergence and downward
causation and things like that
so
you're exactly right benjamin that i do
not use reductionism in this picture
reductionism is a specific kind of
emergence where you say not only
is my higher level theory
a subset of the the lower level theory
but the lower level theory is made of
small pieces
collections of which
are the uh ontological elements of the
higher level theory
in a very straightforward way that does
make sense in a lot of circumstances
like with the atoms in the gas okay the
little cubic millimeter of gas in a
fluid is a whole bunch of molecules okay
it's literally a collection of those
little smaller pieces
but there's other cases where that
doesn't work and part partly why i'm so
sensitive to this is there's something
called quantum mechanics and in quantum
mechanics you can say the classical
world emerges from it but not because
one big classical thing is made of
little tiny wave functions there's still
only one wave function for the whole
world right
uh the way the classical world emerges
from the quantum world is much more
subtle than a naive reductionistic
picture so i'm trying to separate out uh
the all the different ways things could
possibly happen from the specific ways
they happen in the real world that was
the the point of that discussion in the
book
stuart haynes says do you how do you
find living with an electric vehicle has
the range ever been an issue what do you
like most about it and what do you miss
the most from your prior vehicle
um
yeah so as some of you know i have a bmw
i3 if you i'm if you've seen one of
these on the streets you'll recognize it
it's a tiny little car it's about the
size of a mini uh it's kind of space age
looking we call it the space buggy
and one of the
fun things about it is that
it's available or was available i think
they're canceling it um it has been
available with different interior
packages made of different
uh materials so the interior of our
space buggy is like a mixture of fabric
and leather and carbon fiber
and wood oh yeah it would the um what is
the the steering wheel so it's like a
kind of post-modern uh pastiche of
different kinds of things and it's
electric and it's not at all popular
this particular car and the reason why
is they didn't even try to give it a a
long range the range is like 100 miles
purely electric maybe 120 and then there
is a range extender which is like a
little tiny putt-putt engine
uh that is gas driven
but
yeah it took me a while to figure this
out the gas driven putt-putt engine
never drives the car
all it is it's literally i call it a
pop-up engine it's literally from a
moped originally i believe and if you're
running low on uh the electrical charge
you can run the range extender and it
will recharge your battery and then
you're still running on electric so the
actual powertrain of the car is purely
electric but they're sort of like a
backup source of electricity and which
i've never used we've never used the
range extender
many people um for very good reasons uh
get very uncomfortable if their range is
less than 300 miles right and
something that i think is is not said
out loud enough the reason why that's a
problem is because it takes time to
charge your car you know the range on uh
internal combustion engine car isn't
much more than 300 miles but you can go
to the gas station and a minute later
you're full up and then you can keep
going whereas it takes time to charge
your car so that's why things like fuel
cell cars are interesting ideas uh but
they haven't really become practical yet
anyway uh so the whole point of the i3
is you wouldn't want it as your only car
and you wouldn't want it as a car at all
if you led the kind of lifestyle where
you're driving 100 miles every day or
more
but if you live in a big city
or even in a reasonable size suburb
and it's your second car if you're a
two-car household as we are
um then it's perfect i love it i love
that car to death i mean we have a gas
car now
for road trips etc and we have the space
buggy the i3 and almost all the time
we're driving the i3 when there's a
choice because it's quiet
you get this pleasurable
experience of driving by the gas station
and never stopping
um it's very very zippy even though it's
tiny right uh
the acceleration it doesn't go very fast
it's top end speed is not competitive
with a tesla or anything like that but
it's handling an initial burst of speed
are very very good so you really feel
like you're totally in control of what
the car is doing on the road and the
aesthetics are cool and it's just kind
of like a very fun car to drive you just
are smiling when you're driving the i3
so we've been very very happy with that
but i totally get that it wouldn't work
if it was your only car if you had a big
family or for many other things it's a
very niche kind of vehicle
gilles 15 says i read yesterday the nfl
team who won the coin toss since the
introduction of the current nfl overtime
rules has only lost once should the nfl
change its overtime rules to match those
of college football or each team gets
one at least one possession from the 25
yard line um i have no idea whether it
should or not but i strongly suspect it
should so i'm not a football fan anymore
i used to be a football fan as a kid for
various reasons i've stopped following
football so i've not followed these
recent controversies about the overtime
rules the only reason i'm answering this
question i have nothing interesting to
say about it but i have this feeling
that sports leagues are way too
conservative
about changing obviously bad rules and
so even though i don't know the details
of this situation my strong suspicion is
they should change the rule there have
been so many complaints
that's one of those things where
apparently
this year the rule has been coming into
[Music]
being very relevant in the playoff games
over and over again but you should have
known years ago that this was a silly
rule like it's it's some kind of sudden
death
overtime where the first team to score
wins which might make sense in
uh soccer uh regular football but not an
american football that makes no sense at
all so yeah they should change it that's
my thought
johann livgren says
one of weinberg's three conditions for
when a physical system can be described
as an effective field theory is
something called cluster decomposition
which is typically called a type of
locality constraint
but we also know that quantum gravity
will need to have some non-local aspects
does that mean that treating the core
theory as an effective field theory is
actually mistaken or can the core theory
manage to preserve cluster decomposition
while still being non-local
there's a good technical but very good
question the point is that the core
theory is not supposed to
account for gravity in those regimes
where the non-local aspects would be
relevant
so it's true you're correct that there
are reasons to believe that quantum
gravity has some non-local aspects but
what are those reasons those reasons
have to do with black hole information
laws or something like that or you know
very very unlikely phase transition
bubble nucleation kind of things nothing
that is in the everyday life regime the
whole point of the core theory is that
it correctly describes everything that
we know about including gravity in the
everyday life regime in the solar system
okay on the earth the sun
and there there's no non-locality that
you're expecting from quantum gravity
uh so
the core theory is resolutely an
effective field theory and does obey
cluster decomposition and it has a
domain of applicability as we were just
talking about and that domain of
applicability does not include black
holes or the big bang or any other
places where non-locality is expected to
become important
uh mark gregor purse pierce i don't know
how do you pronounce the name sorry mark
says
i've heard many physicists express
disappointment when experiments designed
to find problems with einstein
einstein's general theory of relativity
fail
they say that finding problems with
general relativity would open doors to
new physics from my perspective
experiments that once again support
general relativity simply show
einstein's enduring brilliance i wonder
where you stand on this topic
well look um
many things so
i guess the big picture answer is
all physicists are always going to be
disappointed when
a theory that somebody else came up with
passes an experimental test
roughly speaking because if you are
doing the test and there's two
possibilities you're confirming an
existing theory or finding an anomaly
finding an experimental difference
between what the real world is doing
what the theory is doing uh you're it's
much more interesting to find an anomaly
right because that means that there's a
better theory out there that maybe you
don't have yet but you can start looking
for it whereas if you're just
reconfirming an existing theory that's
very very good work it could be very
very valuable but it's not going to lead
to a breakthrough in inventing a better
theory so that's why people are
disappointed by that if you're professor
einstein you can take personal pleasure
in having your theory pass all these
tests that's great
so that's roughly i think the
perspective that working physicists have
they want useful new input into their
task into their program of building new
theories but also i wanted to comment
because you said
the experiments that support general
relativity show einstein's enduring
brilliance and i don't think that's
right i think that's there's a little
bit of a misunderstanding there
um
i mean if einstein would not be any less
brilliant if an experiment showed a
deviation from general relativity
einstein invented general relativity
that was his brilliance that's already
shown
um it's a wonderful theory for all sorts
of reasons and the fact that it works in
the easy cases is more than enough to
establish einstein's enduring brilliance
what's these experiments are
establishing is not the brilliance of
some human being but the particular way
that nature works
that some theories have certain domains
of applicability that are quite broad
the amazing thing about general
relativity i mean it's amazing from one
perspective and perfectly natural from
another perspective
is that you invent it by thinking about
the solar system like einstein in 1915
you know about cosmology or black holes
right so he knows about newtonian
gravity he knows about relativity
special relativity on the basis of that
he says you know okay what's the
simplest way to reconcile these and he
invents this
brilliant idea of curved space time and
he says okay what's the equation that
curve space time should obey
buy my book for y the right equation
pops out in the way it does but the
point is the equation he comes up with
is more or less unique
given you want a relatively simple
equation that relates the curvature of
space-time to matter and energy you're
going to come up with einstein's
equation einstein did it first but
you're going to do it it's not there
weren't many choices
and the amazing thing is it also works
for pulsars and black holes and the
expansion of the universe and the
microwave background and a million other
things right
we understand why on the basis of how
field theory works general relativity is
a field theory it's a classical field
theory but still
um in the general
realm of field theories you would expect
field theories to work
on long length scales and to break down
at some shorter length scale so if
general relativity works in the solar
system you'd expect it to keep working
cosmologically um not necessarily that
with 100
certainty but that's the e that's the
way to bet so i'm all in favor of people
looking for deviations from general
relativity and cosmology but i don't
expect them to find any
ken wolfe says in the mindscape podcast
episode quantifying the shape of stories
peter dawes talked about some of the
potential dark sides of storytelling
is there any particular popular story be
it a novel movie or television series
that you think has an underlying message
or moral which you regard as being
fundamentally wrong or misguided and why
so yeah i debated about this question
because i don't have a good actual
answer i mean i could you know say that
i don't know some of the
uh iran's novels have a bad moral
message about selfishness or you know
lenny riefenstahl's
movies that were propaganda for hitler
those are bad or the pro-slavery movies
from uh dw griffith bad
okay but those are not you know
currently popular
tv properties or something like that and
i'm sure the answer is yes i'm sure that
there are uh shows on tv right now whose
message were moral i disagree with but i
can't think of any honestly off the top
of my head right now
so
i was originally thinking that it's not
worth answering since i have no good
answers to give you but there's a
underlying issue here that is at least
worth not again not answering so i don't
know the answer to it but worth bringing
up which is
what does it mean
to say
that a story has a message or moral
right
i mean we all know it does i'm not not
arguing that stories don't have messages
or morals but in some sense i mean think
about this potential point of view a
story is just a
recounting of things that happen and
they don't happen in the real world it's
a fictional story but it's a set of
things that happen in this imaginary
world right
okay but we know you can't derive ought
from is so
what does it mean to say that this
particular recounting of events
has a moral or a message
and presumably what it means is that
there is some kind of justice that
occurs that you know people who make the
right choices are rewarded people who
make the bad choices are
punished
and most of the time i think that that's
actually true but sometimes it's not i
mean sometimes we know of stories where
the clearly heroic character
doesn't win in the end right the
character does all the right things and
and nevertheless
uh comes out worse for wear and so
i can't quite um
condense what that means into a simple
statement um
how do we know what the moral is if they
fail like and i think that there's some
complicated kind of subtle subtextual
thing about
the way characters are portrayed as
either uh heroic or or despicable or
whatever but i'm not exactly sure you
know how you could objectively classify
those things so i think that the
morality or message of a story has to do
with
um which actions are treated as heroic
or admirable
but i couldn't tell you
what the rules are for saying oh yes
this story is treating these actions as
heroic or admirable i'm just not sure so
i don't know what the answers are but i
thought that was an interesting uh thing
to think about so i'm glad that you
asked the question
jonathan sirocco says i wanted to know
your thoughts about one common criticism
of string theory namely the
falsifiability of the theory and there's
more to the question you can read uh in
the comments on patreon but uh that's
basically the question you know what
what is the issue with falsifiability
and string theory so there's a couple
issues i mean one is the whole idea of
falsifiability is a little bit overblown
as i've written about in blog posts and
papers uh popper when he was talking
about falsifiability was gesturing
toward
two very important features of a good
physical theory one is that it should be
definite
there are some things that the theory
says are potentially allowed to happen
and some things that are not okay it
cannot literally account for everything
right
and the other aspect that he was
gesturing toward is that there should be
some empirical
way of judging the success of the theory
that's what really matters it's really
those two things that really matter and
he you know attempted to sort of sum
them up
in this single criterion of
falsifiability but it didn't really work
philosophers of science these days don't
buy falsifiability as
the right way of demarcating science
from non-science
physicists love falsifiability because
it's a one phrase
right you don't have to think that hard
like they talk to real philosophers of
science and it sounds like you keep
talking and it's hard and it hurts your
brain you don't want to bother whereas
falsifiability is just a little model
you can put on a bumper sticker that
doesn't make it any more accurate so
there's issues with using falsifiability
in a too simplistic away that's one
thing
but the other is
you know think about
let me before directly addressing string
theory let me give an example of
a failure mode of thinking of
falsifiability is the most important
thing in the world
um one way that a theory might not be
falsifiable
is if there are free parameters in the
theory right like newtonian gravity has
a free parameter newton's constant of
gravitation and you measure it you know
because you know the theory is accurate
in a certain regime you go just measure
the parameter but if you don't know your
theory is right in a certain regime you
might have a parameter
with a feature that as that parameter
gets smaller and smaller it becomes
harder and harder to see any effect of
the theory whatsoever right
like strings are very tiny so it's hard
to see them
um dark matter interacts very weakly in
the limit as dark matter doesn't
interact at all you will never see it in
an experiment in a lab here on earth
okay
so does that
mean
that the theory is not falsifiable
because there are
uh
values of the parameters that would make
the direct implications of the theory
unmeasurable and i say this because many
people talk as if it would that that
counts as not being falsifiable if there
are free parameters that would basically
hide
the theory uh from your view so here's
the problem with that
what if you find the theories right
so an example is cosmic strings okay
cosmic strings are different than string
theory cosmic strings are big cosmic
things uh left over from the early
universe not little tiny things that are
supposed to be elementary particles but
there's this idea that there are
leftover cosmic strings from the early
universe that you know could have a role
in
current astrophysical dynamics but
there's a free parameter what we call
the tension of the string basically the
energy density along the string
and if this if there are lots of strings
and there are very dense high tension it
would be easy to see them
and in the limit as the tension of the
string gets smaller and smaller and
smaller
then you would never see them right if
the if the tension is arbitrarily small
there'll be zero observable effects
so this perspective would say okay
that's not a falsifiable theory you
should not count it
the problem is what if you measure it
what if you do detect it what if you
measure a specific value of the theory
of the of the tension of the strings
because you've seen some gravitational
lensing event or something like that
now you've you've tied yourself in a
philosophical knot where you have to say
well i can't believe the result of that
observation because i've decided this is
not a scientific theory and that's just
silly right
because falsifiability is not the right
way to demarcate scientific theories
from non-scientific theories so that's
analogous to the string theory situation
because string theory like other
approaches to quantum gravity like loop
quantum gravity etc
has you know hand-wavy ways that maybe
it could someday
lead to experimentally testable results
large extra dimensions supersymmetry
things like that it's a tenuous set of
connections
between the predictions of string theory
and potentially observable things but
they are there
and we could easily imagine a situation
where
over the next few years or whatever we
suddenly make a series of experimental
discoveries
that convinces us that string theory is
on the right track but it's also very uh
plausible in fact way more likely
that even if string theory is true it
continues to hide from our direct
experimental probes roughly because
gravity is weak and quantum gravity is
hard to experimentally test nothing
specific with string theory just gravity
uh is the problematic thing here
so
people
have pointed out that in string theory
there are extra dimensions there are
many ways to hide those extra dimensions
and every way leads to a different low
energy version of physics by low energy
version physics i mean for us the core
theory the standard model of particle
physics with its specific
forces and matter particles etc
and there are different ways that could
have turned out if we lived in a world
with a different compactification of the
extra dimensions there are so many
possible ways to compactify the extra
dimensions that you can get almost any
specific version of low energy particle
physics so people make the criticism
that therefore string theory predicts
every possible thing therefore predicts
nothing therefore it's not a theory at
all and i don't believe that either i
mean i think that's just sloppy
reasoning on the basis of people who
don't like string theory because as i
said that's the low energy physics
of string theory string theory comes
into its own at high energies near the
planck scale where it makes definite
predictions for what you would what
would happen if you scattered two
strings off of each other now even there
there are subtleties because of
dualities and so forth but it's very
much in the realm of things where there
are thought experiments we could do that
clearly show that things are behaving in
a stringy fashion or not behaving in a
stringy fashion there's no guarantee
we'll ever be able to do that but in in
sort of the underlying story of what
popper had in mind when he invented
falsifiability the fact that string
theory says that certain things would
happen and certain things would not is
what matters not whether or not you and
i can ever actually do those experiments
okay
felix dare asks a priority question
um and it's a long one buckle up so
say if we take the cat out of the
thought experiment schrodinger's cat and
focus instead on what is going on with
the atom we have a machine which
randomly selects a single atom from a
sealed box containing many identical
radioactive atoms
the machine takes a reading at the exact
point of the atom's half-life if it is
decayed then a macroscopic event a is
triggered like a bell is wrong
if it is not decayed then macroscopic
event b is triggered a firework rocket
goes off so let's say
i would argue says felix
that the atom which is selected from the
container is special in some very
particular way it alone among all the
atoms in the room is able to impact the
wider world around it
each of the macroscopic events in
question could have occurred
spontaneously without any intervention
from the machine but the chances of that
so happening are extraordinarily
unlikely
if i can apply a version of what i
understand to be your explanation of the
multiverse theory the rules have been
rigged so that the universe can split
into only one of two outcomes each of
which was always possible but neither of
which would have otherwise been expected
to occur
the laws of physics ascribed to the atom
are exactly the same as for those left
behind in the container but the selected
atom is special in a very remarkable way
it has been given in effect agency
to choose which event will occur
this agency comes not from anything
particular about that atom but rather
from the structure of all the other
atoms around it the machine the bell the
firework etc
if we are prepared to make this leap
then the same agency could equally be
described be ascribed to the structure
of the atoms inside the human brain
albeit on a much more complicated level
i may perhaps be restating the problem
of consciousness but it seems to me
that the above perspective provides a
route by which the purely quantum
properties of a particular atom
or other subatomic particles can reach
out to influence and perhaps even be
said to communicate with the wider
macroscopic world
okay so i forget whether it edited your
question sorry about that but there's
not a question mark that is lying at the
end of that i will try to comment on uh
what you're getting at because there are
a couple of comments here one is i think
the basic picture is perfectly plausible
the basic picture that
individual quantum events at the atomic
or subatomic level
will usually be unnoticeable to us right
the decay of a single atom is not
something it happens all the time in our
bodies and we don't notice
but in exactly the right circumstances
you can amplify
those quantum events this is a
well-known thing you can take a quantum
event
and if it interacts with the surrounding
materials in exactly the right way
that amplification can become
macroscopic
um no problems with that whatsoever
completely on the right track there uh
now the question is there's two
questions one is
um is it is it does it make any sense to
assign the word agency to this
and i don't think there is that's not
what i mean by agency anyway agency in
in my mind specifically makes sense as a
description of a situation where there
is some immensely complex
situation
where you can't actually model all of
the moving pieces that are that are
doing their thing and therefore it
becomes useful as an emergent higher
level description to ascribe an agent
making choices or to use that language
that ontology to describe what is going
on a single atom just obeying the
schrodinger equation is not in that
situation of enormous complexity where i
have no better way of describing it than
as an agent making choices so i would i
would not want to use that word
but
um what you're getting at with a human
brain is in some sense i think perfectly
reasonable
the
thing that happens in the human brain is
i think the collective behavior of a
whole bunch of things governed by the
laws of physics and so
it's absolutely the case that
whatever is happening in the human brain
is a bunch of atoms doing their thing
now there's a specific question about
whether or not
the quantumness of the individual atoms
matters you know when you hit a baseball
and you follow its trajectory that
baseball is made of atoms and atoms obey
the rules of quantum mechanics but who
cares the baseball is going to obey the
classical equations of motion so the
question is in the particular
configuration of the human brain
we think that they're it the human brain
is much more complex than a baseball uh
there are a lot of moving parts and the
moving parts matter in interesting ways
uh
individual neurons talk to each other
signals get fired back and forth in a
pattern that is hard to predict exactly
what's going on
and those chem those those things that
happen are generally thought of as
neurochemical right they're generally
conceived at the level of neurons doing
things under certain circumstances and
you can talk about the action potential
potential and you know how
what signals the neurons are receiving
and what once they're giving out and so
forth but you could go down to the level
of individual atoms i mean neurons are
small but they're much bigger than atoms
okay there's a lot of atoms in a neuron
so usually the description we use at the
neuron level
the question is i'm finally getting to
it um is it easy or at least plausible
to imagine circumstances under which
a a 50 50
quantum measurement possibility in an
individual atom
can lead to different behaviors in a
neuron that would lead to different
behaviors in a macroscopic person
and that i honestly don't know the
answer it is completely plausible to me
that that could happen i suspect it is
rare i suspect that um because the the
brain has a lot of particles in it many
many many particles you know even though
it has a lot of neurons again those
neurons have a lot of atoms in them and
these signals these electrochemical
signals are still involving a lot of
atoms
i suspect individual quantum
choices or measurement outcomes usually
wash out
but if you're right there on the
precipice halfway between one
possibility and another maybe a single
quantum measurement event really does
matter
i don't think that has anything to do
with at the well it's not a necessary
part of talking about consciousness
let's put it that way i believe that you
could do
everything that is necessary to explain
consciousness using classical physics or
using just the higher level neuron
description
um
but i don't know about that i'm being
open-minded about that maybe someday we
really do need to take into account
these quantum events
to really think about what is happening
in the brain and becoming amplified up
to human actions that's an open
possibility
noble gas says as bayesians we can never
assign 0 probability to anything some
scenarios have vanishingly small chance
of being true but in an expected value
calculation the badness of them is so
great that it overwhelms even the
smallest probability these things cause
me a great amount of psychological
distress even though i assign a very low
likelihood to them for example i lose
sleep over simulation arguments with
dystopian outcomes and quantum
immortality i know you've written about
these topics but you don't seem
distressed by them what advice can you
give to people who know these things are
unlikely but still worry about them
well i think there's at least two things
going on um you're right in the basic
setup uh if you believe in
both quantum mechanics and bayesian
reasoning then there are very unlikely
but very bad events so the two things
that i would emphasize are number one
they're typically
very unlikely
so even if they're very bad
there's no guarantee that even if the
badness is large the product of the
badness times the likelihood is large
you would have to do a very very careful
analysis of that you know back when the
large hadron collider was uh firing up
and people
asked scientists is there a chance it
destroys the earth you know the honest
scientists had to say well there's a
chance
there's always a chance they they
eventually gave up saying that you know
john ellis uh
when he was interviewed on the uh
tonight tonight show no um
jon stewart's show
you know what the show is um he just was
asked about whether the lhc could
destroy the world he said no
that was it that was his answer no it
won't because he knew
that careful parsing of tiny
probabilities was not um useful in that
particular
atmosphere but the point is that the
scientists did very very carefully think
about the probabilities wrote papers
about them did calculations and the
probability's never zero but it's so
very very very tiny that they judged it
not worth thinking about i think that's
generally the case with these kinds of
uh situations the other one which was
pointed out by martin reese on the
podcast episode that i did with him way
back when
um was if you're gonna focus on these
very very unlikely bad events you have
to admit the possibility of very very
likely good events
right like the lhc will give us free
energy
violating the conservation of energy and
providing free power for all of human
eternity there you go it's possible
maybe the lac will allow us to cure all
diseases right so you talk about
simulation arguments with dystopian
outcomes
yes but there's also simulation
arguments with utopian or heavenly
outcomes right and
i think you should just ignore all of
them
i think if they're truly very very low
probability
um you don't i mean the real thing is
not a conviction that the probability is
so low
that when you multiply it by the badness
it's still small but a humble
recognition that the probability is so
low that you don't know what the
probability is right that's the
threshold in my mind that makes it not
worth worrying about once we're talking
about things that are so unlikely
that it is just moonshine for me to
pretend that i know what the probability
is i'm not going to worry about those
things there's enough real world things
out there to worry about and to be happy
about
gregory kusnick says the hard problem of
consciousness is usually framed in terms
of explaining how subjective experience
can emerge from the purely physical
interaction of particles but no one
seems to wonder how say natural
selection emerges from fundamental
physics indeed 50 years before the
formulation of quantum physics and a
century before watson and crick natural
selection was understood as a logical
consequence of imperfectly replicating
information its explanation is
completely disconnected from the
underlying physics of the molecules that
carry that information do you think
consciousness could be like that and its
explanation will be found not by mapping
the brain down to the level of particles
but by developments in cybernetics and
information theory that's shed light on
the nature of complex systems without
reference to the underlying physics
um yeah i think that's
more or less completely obviously true i
would be absolutely shocked if anything
about fundamental physics was useful in
explaining consciousness
the only
point that i have to offer in debates
about consciousness is that we have very
very little reason to imagine altering
fundamental physics to help explain
consciousness uh so in fact this is
exactly my point of view that we should
think of it as an emerging higher level
phenomenon and
i would be
uh very surprised if you couldn't even
think about
uh well i mean you mentioned
information theory and cybernetics those
will undoubtedly be useful i think that
understanding the brain is going to be
the most useful thing right um and i
know that people don't agree with this
the argument against this is that you
can understand everything that the brain
does and still don't have a handle on
subjective experience but if we i
believe that if we truly understood
everything the brain does that when you
feel sad something is going on in your
brain when you experience the color of
red something else is going on in your
brain
we would eventually be done we would
just say that's it this is what is
happening and then the phrase i'm
experiencing the color of red is a way
of expressing something going on the
level of neurons which is also
something going on the level of atoms
and particles right but we don't need to
know what that is to have an explanation
just as with natural selection
jay says
i appreciate it if you could discuss the
physical interpretation of fields i more
or less understand the mathematical
definition but for example i don't
understand where the fields come from
physically were they created the big
bang or already present
are they expanding in lockstep with the
universe or is the universe expanding
via fields that already exist
so
i'm yeah i'm worried jay that you have a
kind of an intuition about fields it is
not quite accurate uh fields are
properties of the universe that are
located at every point in space-time so
they are
coexistent with space time itself
they're not created or destroyed the
fields themselves the field could have a
value of zero at some point so the
particles the particles that are
excitations of the fields can be created
or destroyed but the fields are just
there they come along with the ride once
you have space time you can have
different theories where different
fields come along with the ride but in
any given theory with certain sets of
fields there they are
so what that means is that every point
in space
there's a set of field values for the
different fields for the electron field
for the electromagnetic field and so
forth as space gets bigger
number one you have to ask what you mean
by that space getting bigger you know in
in cosmology we have a perfectly good
understanding of what we mean by that we
mean the distance in between galaxies is
increasing
but at the fundamental physics level
we're less sure that we know what we
mean by that uh
in classical general relativity there
are an infinite number of points between
any two locations in space
and so when we say space expands
there are still an infinite number of
points i mean
in there's there's no mathematically
rigorous sense in which there are more
of them even if they doubled in number
if you know what i mean
uh but anyway that the usual
conventional picture is space gets
bigger and at every point in space the
fields are there they're not causing the
universe to expand or anything like that
uh but they have energy and that energy
does affect the expansion of the
universe
jim watson says in the expanding
universe do we think the planck constant
is really constant or is it that the
constant is changing with the expansion
of space-time
well we certainly think it's constant
uh you can try to do measurements asking
yourself how it would change how
observable things would change if
planck's constant were different
but that's exactly like the speed of
light in the sense that there's a very
real sense which the punch constant is
just equal to one
you can always choose units in which
that's true it's not so much a constant
of nature as it is a conversion factor
between different things going on in
particular it's the
conversion factor that relates quantum
effects to classical ones and so if you
think about what it would mean to change
the speed of light the speed of light is
an easier example so let me talk about
that we can relate it then to plonk's
constant
if you talk about changing the speed of
light you think that makes sense there's
a certain number of meters per second
right 300 000 kilometers per second uh
how hard would it be to change that
number but what you're really doing is
changing the definition of the meter or
the second
uh you can always define the speed of
light to be one light second per second
and in particle physics what it works
out to be is that uh the definition of i
forget which way it goes i think that
it's a definition of a
meter is given in a certain in terms of
a certain number no the definition of a
second is a certain number of cycles of
something uh some atomic transition and
then the definition of a meter is the
distance light travels in a certain in a
second or in a certain fraction of a
second
so to change the speed of light
effectively you i mean you can't in some
sense but you could trick yourself into
thinking that it happened if you changed
all the other constants of nature
in such a way that things seemed the
same except for these uh relationships
between the number of cycles of some
atomic transition and the size of an
atom or something like that okay so
likewise you could imagine some
conspiratorial change in all of the real
constants of nature the fine structure
constant the mass of the electron and so
forth
that we would call it a change in the
planck constant uh there's no reason to
expect that that happens so
i don't think it's a hot topic in
theoretical physics and there's also no
reason to expect that any of those
things change either we are looking for
the individual changes in uh mass of the
electron charge of the electron things
like that but the limits on them already
are pretty good
casey mahone says
how important do you think it is to push
yourself out of your comfort zone part
of me wants to relax and enjoy my simple
life but another part says i'm supposed
to aim for something bigger i feel like
a hobbit in the shire wondering whether
it's a quest i'm meant to embark on for
context i'm in my late 20s so i wondered
if you may have felt similarly at my age
um for the last part of the question i
was very lucky in some sense in that i
knew
what i wanted to do from a very very
young age right that i wanted to get a
phd in theoretical physics think about
the universe and that's what i'm doing
now many many years later uh so i didn't
really um worry too much about that sort
of thing i
knew that i was in the middle of a
journey and it was nowhere near the end
of it yet but more generally speaking
you know many people are not that lucky
and i'm not even sure that uh
i would recommend that you should try to
be that lucky because many people don't
discover
what it is they really want to do until
later and that's completely fine
there's a balance i think between
pushing yourself out of your comfort
zone and just enjoying the simple life
that you have neither one of those two
are bad things enjoying your simple life
is good pushing out of your comfort zone
also good i think it's a very highly
personal decision how to balance those
two things the only non-trivial thing i
can say is of course that there's a
default of enjoying your simple life and
relaxing right pushing yourself out of
your comfort zone is something where
the rewards to that can be a little bit
less tangible a little bit less obvious
and immediate so it's something where
you might have to push yourself to do it
and then find that you're very very
happy you did it right
speaking of we were talking about
working out at the gym earlier same
exact kind of thing like you know i
might be sitting here going i don't want
to do that but then once i actually did
it i'm like i'm very glad i did that
right so it's a competition between your
present self and your future self
i'm in favor of pushing yourself out of
your comfort zone i enjoy it um but i
don't insist that other people enjoy it
uh to the same extent so you have to
pick and choose you know that's not a
choice that other people can make for
you but you got to keep your options
open
amanda bradford says which disciplines
or area of study do you not find very
interesting it's a tough one actually
you know i i thought about it because
there's certainly plenty of things i
don't find interesting but as i thought
about it it's more like specific subsets
of areas i find uninteresting like in
most areas i can think of at least
academic areas
um
i can find some
aspect of those areas you know history
or literature or whatever that i find
really really interesting uh now of
course there are non-academic areas you
know there are uh sports or leisure time
activities that i have zero interest in
um
but i think that's not what you're
asking you're asking about disciplines
or areas of study so yeah i mean that's
that's tough for me i mean i don't want
to see i sound like i'm
interested in everything i'm not even
interested in parts of theoretical
physics
uh but you know i i honestly kind of
feel like i don't want to
make up a couple of them uh just as
examples because
people want to inevitably say i think
that these are intrinsically not
interesting rather than me saying that
my personal interest does not lie there
so i would say that for evidence for
what i think is interesting you know
look uh for how i act and how i talk
look at the things i do talk about those
are things i do think are interesting
and the other things i think are less
interesting that's the way uh you can
collect evidence for those hypotheses
jeff b says
can you give a brief description of the
differences between string theory and
loop quantum gravity and you do you
subscribe more or less to either one
uh i think they're they're quite
different i mean loop quantum gravity is
you know in some sense is a very
conservative program it starts with
einstein's classical general relativity
theory for space time uh it rewrites it
in a certain set of variables and then
it tries to quantize the resulting
theory using techniques of quantization
that have been around for a long time
and you of course immediately run into
problems with that so you try to be
clever about getting around them
i would say honestly i don't think loop
quantum gravity has gotten very far to
be very very honest it's a very obvious
thing to try
uh i'm glad that some people are trying
to do it you never know when they might
have a breakthrough around the corner
but
i would say that things we've learned
from not even necessarily string theory
but but string theorists let's put it
that way because
string theory is a very different
uh
approach where they didn't try to
quantize gravity they're originally
trying to understand the strong
interactions of particle physics and
they stumbled upo upon gravity being
predicted by this idea that there were
strings quantum strings propagating
through a pre-existing space-time
predicted the existence of gravity so
that's already more promising right like
if if the theory hands you gravity when
you weren't even looking for it that's a
promising kind of sign and they've gone
very far now part of why they've gone
very far is because a huge amount of
brain power has been devoted to thinking
about string theory um and they've also
hit obstacles but so far mostly they've
been able to overcome the obstacles you
know there are extra dimensions of space
time but they figured out ways to
compactify them and so forth
and through all this effort to finish
the sentence i started a minute ago um
we've discovered some amazing things
it's all thought american thought
experiment things it's not things we
discovered in a lab but things like um
holography and complementarity are two
of the most obvious things which i think
are profound features that will probably
be part of quantum gravity even if
string theory is not correct
and you know the loop quantum gravity
people did not discover those things uh
they can try x post facto to match them
but you know we got to be fair about
what happened historically that those
things came out of people who were doing
mostly string theory
and so
i'm not sure if either one is right
i think that string theory has
given us a whole bunch of fascinating
results that are
very promising to be part of the
ultimate theory whether or not the
ultimate theory looks like string theory
or not i don't know um you know i think
that we it pays to be humble a little
bit here you know we're trying to do
something in quantum gravity that we
have no right to expect should be easy
you know when i
when i started in this game late 80s
early 90s it was after the first super
string revolution but before the second
superstring revolution so honestly a lot
of uh academics a lot of high-powered
physicists were still very skeptical of
string theory you know they were waiting
for
a really unmistakable experimental
prediction and that's not what happened
but instead what happened was his
revolution in understanding
non-perturbative effects and dualities
and holography and string theory that
was the content of the second super
string revolution and that was enough to
convince a lot of physicists that it was
worth
doing worth hiring people right i mean
that was really it was in the 90s that
really all of your major big shot
universities hired all the strength
theorists that they could find
um there's never been an event that made
all the big shot universities hire all
the quantum gravity people they can find
uh but we'll see you know i think that
uh
what i was trying to say was um
back in the 80s the reason why people
started thinking about string theory
was not because it was the obvious next
thing to think about uh it was because
two things happen at the same time
number one we more or less finished the
standard model right we discovered the w
and z bosons we hadn't discovered the
top quark or the higgs boson yet but
everyone expected that we would
so we had a model that fit all the data
in terms of experiments and number two
the first super string revolution
convinced people that maybe this was a
kind of a peer into a regime of physics
that we had no right to think that we
would be able to solve so easily that
was thought in the 1980s you know i mean
edwin said it was a piece of 21st
century mathematics dropped into the
20th century
um now it turns out that it's hard to
actually connect it to the real world
and i think in retrospect we should be
completely unsurprised by that um if i
needed to pick one i would pick string
theory but uh as many of you know i'm
sort of i'm not really a bandwagon
follower and there's very very large
numbers of extremely smart people
trying to work out string theory and
good for them i'm i'm glad they're doing
it i'm trying my own little quirky
minority point of view on these
questions and i'm happy to be in a much
smaller field than that
joseph dundee says how do you know that
something which has never been observed
is merely very very improbable rather
than impossible for example milk and
coffee spontaneously unmixing or brain
spontaneously forming in a void could
there be an upper limit to the
improbability of an event um
i don't know if there could be an upper
limit to the improbability of an event i
mean maybe there could be if there are
literally a finite number of events in
the history of the universe then one
over that number there's an upper limit
to the improbability of it but i don't
know if that's true and we have no way
of knowing right now uh
my general feeling about these kinds of
questions is you know we'll never know
and it doesn't matter if there's a
difference between very very improbable
and impossible if the very varies are
powerful enough you know if the chances
that in the entire history of the
universe past present and future
a certain kind of event happens with
probability 10 to the minus a billion
then what's the difference between that
and being impossible we don't need to
know the difference between those two
things it's for all intents and purposes
not going to happen for milk and coffee
spontaneously unmixing or brains
spontaneously forming in in a void our
current best understanding is those are
very very improbable they're not
impossible no one says that those are
impossible they're just very very
unlikely but if they're unlikely enough
you get on with your life
jirosh says what is a degree of freedom
for physicists it seems to me that it
indicates different things in different
subfields
degree of freedom is just a way of
saying something that can happen
something that can change a quantity
that can change that's what a degree of
freedom is so literally if you have a
single particle
in three dimensions it has six degrees
of freedom because there are three
numbers that tell you where it is and
three additional numbers that can tell
you how it can move so the state of the
particle is given by those six different
numbers that's six degrees of freedom uh
now to be fair we'd like you say like
you imply we don't use it
very consistently so if we have a field
theory like let's say you have a scalar
field theory so that's just one field
one number at every point in space
people will often call that one degree
of freedom even though really it's an
infinite number of degrees of freedom
because it's a different value of the
field at every point in space
but the infinity from the number of
points in space is taken for granted you
say it's one degree of freedom you're
supposed to figure out that means per
point of space that's why you do have to
keep your uh wits about you a little bit
but that's what it means something that
can change as opposed to
if you have something like newtonian
gravity okay in newtonian gravity
there's no gravitational waves if you
wave the
earth if you move the earth its
gravitational field changes but it
changes instantly throughout space it
doesn't propagate out at a speed so in
newtonian gravity if you know what the
mass is doing
of different objects in the universe you
automatically instantly know the
gravitational field that's not true in
general relativity in general relativity
there's a separate thing that can happen
space-time can oscillate all by itself
so in general relativity there are
degrees of freedom of gravity in empty
space in newtonian gravity they're not
there's gravity in empty space but it is
entirely tied to
the matter therefore it's not a degree
of freedom it's not a separate thing
that can change independently of
everything else
alexandra bates says what is the most
difficult physics problem you have
solved what made it so difficult
yeah i thought about this question and
it's a difficult question to answer
because um it turns me mean by difficult
you know on the one hand like what is
the most
uh
sharp insight that one ever had what is
the aha moment and honestly you know for
better for worse my my most obvious aha
moment was back in graduate school this
often happens
but i was working with eddie farhi and
alan guth on can you make time machines
in three dimensions can you build closed
time-like curves in gravity in a world
of point particles in two dimensions of
space and one dimension of time
which is equivalent to a world with
cosmic strings that are perfectly in
three dimensions that are perfectly
straight and parallel to each other so a
cosmic string has a direction in which
it's moving and if it's perfectly
straight then you can ignore that
direction and so three dimensions just
become two
the reason why you would care about this
weird physical setup is you can solve
all the equations exactly it's a much
easier system to look at than
real three-dimensional gravity with
black holes or whatever
so
we were thinking about that inspired by
work by richard gott who had claimed
that you could imagine time machines in
these systems and what we argued is that
you could
write down what what god did was he
wrote down a
cosmological solution in some sense a
solution to the entire space time of the
universe that did indeed contain closed
time-like curves but what we asked was
could you start in a universe that did
not have closed time-like curves in the
past and then create them by some
dynamical process and so we wrote one
paper where you know we just worked hard
and banged our heads against it and and
said here's some small evidence that you
can't
but then we wanted to you know go
further and like dot all the i's cross
all the t's
and uh really make a proof
and we really struggled with making this
proof and alan in particular uh you know
did a numerical simulation showing that
there's no region of parameter space
where it would work but we still
couldn't find uh a reason why it didn't
work
and then i happened to be giving a
seminar at the university of alberta and
i was talking to don page
and he mentioned a fact that i didn't
know or maybe i had heard but forgotten
about the lorenz group
in two plus one dimensions the lorenz
group the space of all lorenz
transformations okay
namely that it has a geometry and the
geometry looks like that of a space-time
and the space-time is anti-de-sitter
space
these days anti-desire space is a big
deal but back then almost no one was
familiar with it so
i took that fact that was it just a fact
and that was very provocative to me i
was in my you know stage of my life when
uh geometry and topology were
very very fascinating to me and i was
trying to learn all i could so i thought
about what it meant that the set of
lorenz transformations in two plus one
dimensions looks like anti-de-sitter
space and what i realized on the plane
ride home by sketching things is that
this answers all of our questions that
if you think about the space of all
lorenz transformations in three
dimensions as anti-de sitter space then
you can instantly prove you can't build
a time machine without starting with one
from simple geometric arguments drawing
lines on pieces of paper um and that was
that was just wonderful that was you
know one of those events like literally
on
writing the plane back from your seminar
you have the aha moment that solves this
problem and we used that uh in our
follow-up paper
um on the other hand sometimes what do
you mean by the most difficult problem
is
the one you just gotta grind through
right the one where there are no aha
moments available and you just have your
equations in front of you and it's gonna
be pages and that's what it's gonna be
like and i've had a couple of papers
like that also um
about the microwave background about
supergravity
uh we i did a bunch of things as a
postdoc on um dynamically triangulated
two-dimensional gravity that required
many pages of algebra and calculus uh
many little numerical simulations it was
an enormous amount of work right
and again
you get the end the answer at the end of
the day it's a little bit less
intellectually satisfying than the aha
moment but there is honor in honest work
and i put that in as well but you know
none of these are uh
really fascinating problems like to get
just be more specific the microwave
background thing that we did this is
with my friend ted pine who also
trivia ted and i wrote this paper on the
cosmic microwave background but ted is
also the musician responsible for the
music in the mindscape podcast at the
beginning and the end his band euphonic
is the is the band that is playing so he
he's the one who lent me the music for
the podcast um but he was an expert on
perturbation theory in general
relativity back when we were both grad
students and so i was a postdoc we wrote
this paper on
second order perturbation gravitational
perturbations of the cosmic microwave
background so people had just discovered
the anisotropies of the cosmic microwave
background the kobe satellite etc um so
they'd worked out the predictions going
back to peebles and other people that's
why he won the nobel prize
for what those were supposed to be and
we asked the question okay what is what
is the next order effect what is the
higher order and perturbation theory now
in fact the important higher order and
perturbation theory terms are not
gravitational they're you know the thus
primordial plasma is sloshing around in
complicated ways and that's really what
you want to study but that sounds
complicated so ted and i just looked at
gravity just looked at the propagation
of light from the microwave background
surface to today
being buffeted about by gravitational
perturbations the gravitational lensing
we were referring to earlier and we
worked it all out systematically
and we found that there were you know
some terms that people had guessed at
and there were some extra terms that
people had not guessed at
and we we were completely of the opinion
that you know look the microwave
background was discovered in the 60s it
took 30 years uh 25 or 30 years to
discover the
anisotropis probably be another 25 years
before this is relevant
sadly that was more than 25 years ago so
now it's very relevant um and people
cite that paper it was not you know the
most systematic or useful paper but it
was first to point to certain things it
was a tremendous amount
of algebra i gotta say once you get into
second order perturbation theory and
general relativity even if your sites
are relatively modest it's going to be a
lot of algebra there you go
igor parshkin says while doing my
undergrad in physics how much should i
allow myself not to understand fully
what i mean is it often happens that
we're learning something as i can learn
how to do but not really sure what i'm
doing but as soon as i start digging
we're off to the next chapter how much
should i let myself go unlearned while
moving forward
there's another question of you know
taste and and personal preference here
because certainly
to some extent you should let yourself
go unlearned while moving forward you
don't need to master every step before
going on to the next one in fact it's
very often the case that you don't
master earlier steps until later you
realize oh that's why that was important
so you know it's very important to kind
of
remember what the ideas are
and where they might be applicable you
know i had this i sometimes tell the
joke that the real reason to own
to take undergraduate physics courses
is so that you know where the answers
are in the books so that you go through
the textbook and you know where the
formula is for the laplace transform of
something or something like that right
like you've heard there was an idea and
you don't remember but you sort of
remember where it is in the book that's
like the most important thing that you
learn in undergraduate physics classes
so it's great to master things of course
i don't want to say don't do that but it
is not necessarily a disaster if you
don't master everything along the way
now it can accumulate right if you
continue not mastering anything you're
going to get in trouble that's why i
can't really give you very specific
advice here but don't panic just because
everything is not crystal clear the
first time around
bob thomason says
among your scientifically oriented
podcasting peers you are much more
sympathetic with the current racial
justice movement for example i can't
imagine i can't imagine them having
cornell west on their podcasts can you
sum up your take on the state of racial
justice in america today so um that's
asking a lot my take on the state of
racial justice in america probably i
can't do justice to that one as it were
but you know i don't think it's good the
state of racial justice in america i
don't think it's uh
uh going out on a limb to say that you
know look i think there's a lot of
racism out there
and i think that a lot of the
modern realization is that racism can be
kind of
hidden but still really impactful it
doesn't need to be blacks cannot drink
of this water fountain right there are
quieter
less obvious ways uh that policies and
personal opinions and personal actions
can have devastatingly powerful
differential effects on people because
of their skin color i think that's a bad
thing and we should try to fix it um the
other thing of course is that there are
many people who seem to think that the
real tragedy is not racism but being
accused of racism
and i don't agree with that i think that
you know if if racism exists and we're
trying to fix it then certain things are
going to be accused as racist and
sometimes they'll go too far right
sometimes there there will be
accusations of racism that are not
completely accurate that you can't make
an omelette without breaking some eggs
that doesn't mean it's right that
doesn't mean you shouldn't fix it when
that happens or argue against it etc but
i don't think that the existence of the
occasional
overreach when
fighting racism is really the problem i
think the problem is racism racism is
bad we should get rid of racism that is
my take on the state of racial justice
in america today
i'm going to group a couple questions
together here tyler whitmer says how
excited are you about getting images and
data from the james webb space telescope
and is there anything in particular
you're looking forward to learning from
it
kyle moore says with the jwst looking
like it will get to l2 successfully and
without any issues what kinds of
questions should we be able to answer in
the next 10 years with jwst's power
and jay a fail says what discoveries are
you most excited to see come from the
james webb space telescope so clearly
there's some interest out there um you
know i'll be look very honest here
what the james webb space telescope is
going to do is going to be amazing stuff
that doesn't really intersect with my
own personal research interests you know
cosmology and physics more generally are
big fields people do different kinds of
things
what jwst is really optimized for is
mostly looking for galaxies very very
far away another phenomena in the
medium-term early universe so long after
the microwave background but earlier
than nearby galaxies the reason for that
is because it's an infrared telescope so
if you have a redshift then if you have
something object some object that is
giving off
visible light very far away it'll be
redshifted in the infrared and jwst can
see it so how galaxies formed what
happened in those early days of the
formation history of galaxies is a
crucially important question that jwst
is really going to go after as a bonus
it'll be really really good for
exoplanets both finding them and then
investigating them when they're there so
all the stuff is really fascinating and
interesting none of it is what i do for
a living um
i'm not sure what instrument one could
even imagine building that would give
great evidence that bears on the
questions that i personally am
interested at a research level
which is why i'm thinking about the
emergence of space time and the
foundations of quantum mechanics rather
than building specific testable models
that you can probe and experiments
because i don't know what those
experiments would be
so i'm a fan of the jwst as a fan as
everyone else in the world is but i have
no special research level knowledge of
what it's going to do
f sub h says it seems to me that entropy
is something that emerges qualitatively
on the macroscopic level but how should
we think about it on the microscopic for
example we can say that a castle made of
sand is more ordered than a pile of sand
but if we think about each individual
grain of sand on the micro level isn't
that configuration of the grains of sand
that makes up a random pile just as
ordered or disordered as the
configuration that creates a castle uh
sure
yeah 100 there's is no reason to think
about the concept of entropy on the mac
on the micro level entropy is a
macroscopic concept it's a concept that
gains relevance from coarse graining
from thinking about systems from the
point of view of incomplete information
that you know some certain features of
the system but nowhere near the whole
thing so i think that's exactly right
that's how entropy works if you know all
of the micro data there's no reason to
ever talk about entropy
nicolo paratini says do you think
there's any correlation between the
expansion of the universe and the
increase in entropy
i mean there's a correlation
yes entropy is increasing and the
universe is expanding that's what a
correlation means now probably what
you're asking about is there any causal
relationship between them and the answer
there is yes yes and no it depends on
exactly how you parse that question the
fact that entropy is increasing and the
fact that the universe is expanding have
no necessary relationship you could very
easily have a collapsing universe a
contracting universe in which entropy
was also increasing
however it is a feature of our
particular universe rather than the
space of all possible universes that
when the universe was smaller the scale
factor was smaller things were closer
together the density was higher the
entropy was lower so that single fact
the initial conditions of the universe
in which the universe was both dense and
low entropy
set up simultaneously the fact that the
universe is expanding and the fact that
entropy is increasing
so it's not that entropy increase drives
the expansion or vice versa they are
both driven by this particular initial
conditions that we had near the big bang
rob f says
i've read that there is no arrow of time
in fundamental equations of physics and
that the feature that provides the
forward arrow of time we observe the
universe is increasing entropy for the
second law
my question is in the extremely distant
future when entropy has effectively
reached a maximum and can therefore
increase no further does this mean the
time itself will cease or have no or
ceased
the time itself will cease or will cease
to have meaning
uh no it does not mean that what it
means is that time will not have an
arrow anymore i said this in different
places in different ways but
you have to distinguish between time as
a coordinate on space time and the arrow
of time which is an important feature of
it in our real world but not a necessary
feature just with the concept of time
again think about space
there is no arrow of space if you're out
there in the vacuum all directions look
the same that doesn't mean that space
doesn't exist or ceases to have meaning
it just doesn't have narrow time could
easily exist and things could change and
evolve in a way that wasn't directed
overall and therefore time would have no
arrow so that will be the case uh when
the universe is in closer to its
equilibrium state
basad mir hashim says do you think that
all the various forms of fine tuning
from the very low entropy of the
universe to the relative masses of the
up and down quark can be explained by
one principle is that the principle that
there are many universes and we happen
to live in one suitable for life uh aka
the anthropic principle it's it's
possible you know i think that
there are some examples of fine-tuning
so let's put it this way
fine-tuning can be thought of as from a
physicist perspective some parameters
are taking on some purportedly special
values
uh that could be very different
and
why are the values this particular
number rather than a more generic number
so you notice that in that in those
words i never talked about life or
complexity or anything like that that's
what physicists mean by fine-tuning so
when physicists say there is a hierarchy
problem
the mass of the higgs boson is
fine-tuned it's much much lower than its
natural value at the planck scale
nothing to do with life or anything like
that okay
so
what you want to ask for this question
for the anthropic principle the
anthropic principle if it works that is
to say if we are in a kind of universe
where it applies where there are many
different conditions in many different
places and therefore there's a selection
effect you would only observe certain
kinds of conditions those that are
hospitable to the existence of life
then
maybe
you can explain some of these apparent
physicist fine-tunings by saying that if
they weren't fine-tuned life wouldn't
exist and maybe the masses of the up and
down quarks are an example of that
but we think that other fine-tunings
exist that are not examples of that um
the higgs boson is an example we we
think and maybe this is not true but
according to our current best guesses
the mass of the higgs boson could have
been way bigger and still life could
exist okay
um
there's actually debate about this to be
honest but it is certainly something
that is i think the conventional view
and
what that means is that there's a fine
tuning that is not explained by the
anthropic principle an even better
example is the low entropy of the early
universe that we just talked about now
you need some low entropy for life to
exist but the entropy in the early
universe was way way way way way lower
than it needs to be to account for the
existence of life
so you need more than simply an
anthropic explanation so even if the
anthropic principle works for some
things i think that there are other
things which it doesn't help for so i i
left out the best example
there's something called the strong cp
problem there's a parameter called theta
qcd
in the strong interactions which governs
how much violation of cp symmetry you
have from the strong interactions and
it it's called theta because it's an
angle
the physical effects of this number are
the same if you change theta by theta
goes to theta plus two pi okay two pi
radians
and so you would expect naturally it's a
number between zero and two pi or maybe
between zero and pi because the sine
doesn't really matter but we have limits
on it i forget what the current limits
are but there it's less than ten to the
minus 9 or something like that so this
number theta qcd is much much smaller
than it needs to be
has zero connection to life so we need
some dynamical or other mechanism to
explain that that's why axions were
invented to explain exactly that
problem brad malt says in the particle
at the end of the universe you explained
how the higgs field gives mass to
particles since mass must be conserved
does that mean that the higgs field
doesn't change value when the lhc
creates new higgs boson or when a higgs
boson decays and since the mass of an
object is the same everywhere does this
mean the higgs field has the same value
everywhere
so last question first yes the higgs
field has the same value everywhere
except for when you make a higgs boson
so there's a background value that is
more or less very very close to being
fixed everywhere if you start it
vibrating that counts as a higgs boson
so the value is changing by a little bit
but the higgs boson decays away in a
zeptosecond which is saying that the
energy in those vibrations is being
transferred to vibrations in other
quantum fields that is to say the higgs
is decaying into photons or electrons or
what have you um when you make a higgs
boson in the lhc or whatever you're
making one of these localized
excitations you're not changing the
overall value of the higgs boson
everywhere and you're certainly not
changing the mass of anything you're
making a higgs boson but electrons
elsewhere
other than where you've made the higgs
boson are unaffected by what you just
did
finally what i need to say is that mass
is not conserved mass we've known that
mass is not conserved for a long time
uh ever since einstein explained to us e
equals m c squared right this is how you
can make atomic weapons because you can
turn mass into energy using equals m c
squared it's energy that is conserved
and even energy is not exactly conserved
for various subtle reasons in gr and
quantum mechanics but roughly speaking
energy is conserved and so
what happens is when the higgs boson
changes it changes its value
from
zero to some non-zero number at the
electroweak phase transition it gives
mass to a whole bunch of ambient
particles those particles gain energy
because you're giving them mass but
there's a huge amount of energy locked
up in the higgs field as it's evolving
and that energy is diminishing so
basically you're just transferring
energy from the higgs field to all the
particles all around it
and that's part of the process you need
to take into consideration when you
study the dynamics of the electro weak
phase transition if that's something you
ever want to do
angelo ferrari says are virtual
particles really popping in and out of
existence and being exchanged by real
particles you know there's another
yes and no kind of answer to the
question um
not really is the short answer because
really what's going on are quantum
fields that's always the answer
and forget about
um something esoteric like black holes
or hawking radiation that's also true
just when particles scatter off of each
other
the picture of virtual particles as
invented by feynman and others when you
draw feynman diagrams the virtual
particles are the particles that only
are on the interior of the finding
diagram the particles that do not either
come in from the past or go out to the
future but just appear in the interior
lines and loops of the diagram
and this is a way mathematically
of characterizing the effects of the
vibrating quantum fields that's really
what's going on in some sense however
you know it's a really good picture it's
a really good uh way of both calculating
and thinking about what is going on
that's why i said the answer is sort of
yes and no because
it's fine to think about virtual
particles doing what we do in the
finding diagrams now on the third hand
um in the vacuum in empty space it's
kind of not fine to think about the
virtual particles popping in and out of
existence because that gives you a bad
impression of what's happening the
vacuum quantum state is stationary
the state is the same at every moment of
time it is not evolving in any way in
particular
particles are not not there one moment
and then there another moment because
they've popped in and out of existence
the language of virtual particles
popping out of existence is just
supposed to be a way of giving you
intuition for what the quantum state is
doing and in this case the quantum state
is not doing anything so i wouldn't take
that metaphor too seriously in that case
donald hawk says i went to villanova
from 1977 to 1981 and while an atheist i
did enjoy the required religion related
courses did you have similar experience
while there uh yes i enjoyed all my
religion courses i think i took three i
think that was the number of uh required
courses i had to take
um my there was like an intro course on
uh
something about the experience of
christianity or something like that but
it had a really good professor i was
uninterested in the subject matter well
actually that's not true even even at
that level um the subject matter is kind
of fascinating i have to say you know
christianity especially early
christianity and um all the different
texts and things like that uh that when
people were arguing about what was
supposed to be their doctrine that stuff
is fascinating when we got to the later
stuff the 20th century stuff it was a
little bit beyond my um sphere of caring
about but still you know it's always
interesting to hear smart people talk
about difficult ideas so that was fun i
took another course on death and dying
that was interesting intrinsically and
there was another course like on
hermeneutics in religion um
uh you know one applying uh continental
philosophy ideas to the ideas of
religion so that was also very
interesting just philosophically
speaking
douglas albrecht says could you explain
why you were so confident that the wave
function is reality rather than just a
great tool for explaining it um i mean
confident is always a dangerous word you
know there's a technical sense of the
word confident which means that i put a
high credence on it there's an informal
sense means that i'm sure it's right but
i'm not sure that it's right you know
like any good scientific theory we do
our best but we always have a chance
that we're wrong so i do think it's
probably uh represents reality more or
less faithfully um why do i think that
well because that's a theory that fits
all the data and is extraordinarily
simple it's really the simplest theory
you can even imagine along these lines
all other theories are more complicated
so i don't see the motivation for trying
to do something different
i the only motivation i see for trying
to do something different is we don't
know yet let's keep an open mind which
is fine and people can work on that in
this particular corner of idea space i
just want to work on the thing i think
is most likely to be right
liam mccarty says hilbert's sixth
problem was to excimatize physics in his
words to treat in the same manner by
means of axioms
those physical sciences in which today's
mathematics already plays an important
part as far as i'm aware this has only
been partly achieved as some parts of
physics like quantum field theory have
no axiomatic formulation today do you
think trying to aximitize physics is a
worthwhile pursuit or is it merely a
mathematical interest and irrelevant to
physics
i think the important thing to first
note here is that we're not even going
to succeed in axiomatizing mathematics
which is another big thing that hilbert
cared about but kurt gertle with
girdle's theorem and uh other people
showed that this is not going to happen
you're not going to do it it's always
going to be true mathematical statements
that you're not going to be able to
prove deduce from axioms um so
aximitizing things has lost some of its
luster since hilbert had these ambitions
i think um
the better thing to say is you would
like your physics theories to be as
comprehensive as possible in the sense
that we talked about earlier with
domains of applicability and also
completely well-formed whatever that
well-formed formulation might be whether
it's axioms or something else you want
the theories to be clear you want them
to apply everywhere they can you want
them to be coherent compatible with each
other etc i mean that basic program is
absolutely crucial whether or not
it takes the form of explicit axioms or
not
dan inch says can you give us an update
on the cats are they both happy is ariel
getting a nice drippy shower each
morning uh you're asking this at the
wrong time dan um the cats lead a very
very good life and they are almost
always very happy and ariel does get a
shower and post shower lap time every
morning uh but they just have gone to
the vets
recently and we did something just for
scheduling purposes we usually don't do
which is that caliban went to the vet
one day i guess sorry ariel went one day
and caliban went on a different day
rather than bringing them together at
the same time and uh as sometimes
happens ariel's the more high-strung one
like caliban he just he's chill he
doesn't really care what's going on he
doesn't want to go to the vet but if you
take him he's like okay here i am at the
vet here i am back
and ariel gets really annoyed with us
taking her to the vet and so she got
really annoyed when caliban came back
because he smelled like the vet he
didn't smell like caliban anymore and so
she was hissing at him and she didn't
have anything to do with him it took a
good you know 24 hours of uh coddling
them
and other kind of strategies to get them
to snuggle up together at night as they
usually do but they're back to doing
that so i think that even though there's
still some tiny uh frustrations
on evidence uh mostly they're they're
pretty happy right now they're they're
very healthy you know uh cats they're
just going to the vets for checkups
there's nothing wrong with them
steven asks
if democracy is the best method we have
for addressing the dissatisfactions of
the working class poorer people
why isn't it absolutely necessary when
democracy is seriously challenged to
advocate for it until it is secure
then we can turn our advocacy hours to
other multifaceted social problems like
climate change bigotries technical
puzzles all of these problems are hard
they're harder than physics as noted in
the podcast but we agree that without
democracy they are much harder to solve
no
um
i get it and i think i'm i'm
pretty much on board with this which is
why i
spend a lot more time talking about
democracy on my podcast than i otherwise
would than i would have ten years ago
let us say
um of course there's a question being
begged here about whether or not
democracy is the best method we have for
addressing the dissatisfactions of the
working class i think it is but i don't
think it's obviously that um let's put
it this way democracy has failed to
address the dissatisfactions of the
working class or more broadly um to
really do as much for the less off with
less well-off members of society than it
could
um i think it's a dramatic failure of
our modern democratic system and that's
part of why it's in trouble um it's just
not
doing what it's supposed to do now i'm
completely on board i'm of the opinion
that it can and should and might if we
if we do it correctly so i'm not using
this as an argument against democracy
but as a
as an argument against being complacent
just because you have democracy
everything should be fine okay but with
that out with all that out of the way
what is the amount of effort we should
turn to
preserving democracy uh should we
prioritize it over climate change and
things like that
here i would say that we should have the
ability to do more than one thing at
once we should be able to both walk and
chew gum at the same time
we should be able to preserve our
democracy and
ameliorate climate change and think
about the emergence of space time from
quantum mechanics there the important
question is how do you
balance the different amounts of effort
you put into different things and there
there's a complicated thing at the
individual level what are your personal
skill sets what are your personal
interests etc i i do it's a hard
question because
maybe i just like doing physics more so
i want to think about physics but it's
not going to help me if democracy
collapses
um so i see an argument that i should
work even much harder than i am at
preserving democracy it's frustrating
cause it's not clear what that work
would entail but the other thing is
and maybe this is even a darker
contemplation uh the pos the prospect
that democracy collapses and in some
ways things don't change that much right
if people just don't care
about democracy you could easily imagine
a system which for at least a couple
decades maybe longer than that
power was concentrated in the hands of a
small number of people or in some subset
of our population anyway
and still
life more or less went on you know the
trains run and you go to school and
teach your classes and whatever and
gradually
power and wealth and
opportunities and dignity become more
and more concentrated until people get
pissed off and have another revolution
or something like that but but we we
can't imagine that you know if democracy
falls it will instantly be like 1984.
um i mean i think that that's maybe the
thing that i worry about the most is
that we will lose
our democracy and not care you know not
not really be outraged by it nearly as
much as we should
uh so now now i'm depressed so yes we
should fight harder for democracy that's
the lesson that is absolutely what we
should all be thinking about i agree
with that spirit one way or the other
paul hess says why is a wave so
concentrated in one specific place that
we perceive it as a distinct tiny
particle in one place instead of the
wave being spread out much more widely
through space
i don't know paul how is this question
going to help us save democracy this is
this is now what's in my head but
actually this is a very good question
because
if you think about the schrodinger
equation or other equations of
fundamental physics for the waves that
we have in quantum field theory it is
very natural that wave-like
oscillations in a field want to spread
out if you poke your finger into the
surface of a pond ripples move out in
all directions um and so why in the
world do particles in the real world
have something like a location in space
at all rather than just being spread out
all over the place and actually you know
the
this i think you could easily take years
of quantum mechanics and no one truly
answers this question for you or you
know the answer is implicit in many
little pieces of things that you learn
and you have to put it together yourself
a huge part is played by the fact that
most particles are in the form of atoms
right you know a free electron the wave
function of an electron all by itself
out there in the world would indeed
spread out all over the place and maybe
you wouldn't notice because you don't
notice until you measure it or it gets
measured or decohered somehow by
interacting with other particles around
it which might happen pretty quickly
actually
but it would in principle all by itself
if there's nothing else in the universe
it would just spread out
but an electron that is bound to a
proton
its natural wave form are those orbitals
uh that you learned about in high school
chemistry right they are localized near
the proton or near the nucleus in
whatever atom they are in so it is the
attraction of the proton that confines
the wave function of the electron and
the proton or the the nucleus or
whatever is a lot heavier so it spreads
out a lot more slowly that's the other
piece of information you would get but
it wouldn't be connected um heavy things
spread out a lot more slowly in terms of
the propagation of their wave functions
so once you get to something like the
earth which is a big heavy thing it has
a wave function and the center of mass
of that wave function spreads out almost
not at all not quite not at all but
almost not at all so once you get to the
big macroscopic world the spreading is
just so gradual that you and i don't
notice
sid huff says
in a graduate course on research methods
which emphasize scientific principles
and procedures such as hypothesis
generation data gathering and analysis
and hypothesis testing
occasionally a student would ask whether
the curriculum would address other ways
of knowing
usually a student from a non-western or
indigenous culture in your view do any
of these other ways of knowing whatever
that may mean deserves time and
attention in a research methods course
how would you respond to such a
questioning student
well i'm not exactly sure what course
you're talking about but if the course
is called research methods presumably
it's a course on research methods in
some particular discipline i'm sure that
there are courses on research methods in
economics or computer science or physics
or what have you
and
those courses will quite rightly
focus on the research methods that are
actually used in those disciplines
whatever they are
so you know there might be other
research methods or other ways of
knowing i don't know where you want to
draw the boundaries between those
but there's no uh
expectation that a course called
research methods in sociology should
teach you every possible way of knowing
it should teach you research methods in
sociology
as a broader question the value of other
ways of knowing it's going to depend a
lot on the way of knowing that you're
talking about some of them are going to
be nonsense some might be very useful
that's an empirical question you know
tell me what you've learned to show us
what has actually been achieved by this
way of knowing and then we can judge it
empirically that's what i would suggest
doing
pablo's papa giorgio says are you
confident that physics will find the
theory or what if we bump into hard
dualities suppose we end up with
multiple conceptually different models
that each describe fully and perfectly
what we can observe nature doing uh
that'd be fine
i mean there's two possible things going
on here and neither one bothers me at
all one is you have multiple
conceptually different models that are
exactly like you said describing fully
and perfectly what nature does
then they're the same model i mean
they're just the same thing going on in
different language right the hamiltonian
versus lagrangian formulations of
classical mechanics are just different
languages to describe the same thing and
in that case who cares i'm glad that
there are multiple models i think that
they're just describing the same stuff
using different words another
possibility which is more interesting
but also doesn't bother me is that we
find that
we have a set of models with overlapping
but non-equivalent domains of
applicability
so this is the case
in the domains of applicability
discussion we had earlier where you have
two domains of applicability that
intersect in a venn diagram sense so
there's some region where they both
apply but there's also regions where one
applies but the other doesn't
and together
these models describe all of nature okay
that would also not bother me at all i
mean that would just be okay the way
that we describe nature is through this
set of overlapping models uh who cares
like i don't think there's any virtue in
saying that i have a single vocabulary
that describes everything what i want to
do is describe nature accurately in as
wide a domain of applicability as i
possibly can so we're nowhere near any
of these becoming realistic questions to
worry about but that would be my feeling
uh at the present moment
andrew goldstein says
in the next two or three decades could
artificial intelligence advance to the
point where it explains how living cells
emerge from the information encoded in
genes which i consider the
quintessential example of emergence
however long it takes i think it will be
defined by the understanding of
synthesis and growth not by reduction
and analysis what do you think
um
first a little gloss on emergence you
can hear caliban in the background he's
he's meeping um
i'm not sure if this is a quintessential
example of emergence because you are
precisely doing what uh i warned against
doing in my notion of emergence you're
using emergence as a process
that evol that unfolds over time how
living cells emerge from the information
encoded in genes
in my way of thinking there is a level
of talking about genes and chemicals and
proteins and another way of talking
about cells and organs and organisms
and both those simultaneously exist it's
not that one turns into the other
they're both simultaneous ways of
talking about the same stuff
now your question i mean there still is
a question about how living cells do
emerge from the information encoded in
genes in that
uh um
in the sort of more everyday notion of
emergence honestly i don't think that's
that hard a problem um it's certainly
hard i don't want to denigrate the work
being done by people who think about
these questions but there's no
roadblocks there to figuring it out i
don't even think i don't see a reason to
suspect that you would need artificial
intelligence to do that it's a
complicated problem because it's right
there at the boundary where you have
enough atoms and in your molecules to
make them complicated but not so many
that uh you can ignore their individual
peculiarities uh so it's a rich problem
and there's a lot of subtleties and it's
going to require work but it's just good
old science work uh and i think that
it's proceeding at a great pace and so
i'm very optimistic that it will happen
that will really understand how you go
from chemicals to life uh and i can't i
can't tell you when sorry about the next
two or three decades i'm very very bad
at predicting time scales that's just a
hard thing to do
frank layman says so i am laughing at
our cat just meowing in the background
maybe he heard his name being mentioned
in the podcast uh frank lehmann says 15
years ago i listened to your teaching
company lectures on dark matter and dark
energy and was amazed by how such a
humongous portion of the universe's
makeup was a recently discovered and b
so deeply mysterious 15 years later have
physicists made much progress on either
front and understanding the dark sector
at the very least are there hypotheses
for what make up dark matter and dark
energy you mentioned 2007 that are now
more or less popular or supported
so there hasn't been that much progress
there hasn't been dramatic progress or
you would know or we'd be talking about
it i mean the rough picture that i
sketched out 15 years ago where there's
dark matter and dark energy
five percent of our universe by mass is
ordinary matter 25 dark matter 70 dark
energy
we don't know what dark matter is but
it's some particle probably it could be
black holes but probably particles uh
that interact with each other very
weakly and move slowly
we don't know what the dark energy is
but it's probably just vacuum energy
cosmological constant if it's not it's
some dynamical thing that evolves slowly
okay that's what we knew 15 years ago
and that's still what we know today um
the only progress that's been made has
been of a negative variety you know we
have been looking for small changes in
the density of dark energy over time but
haven't found any so our limits are
better now than they were before we've
been looking for dark matter particles
either created in the lab or bumping
into particles here on earth we haven't
seen that either so our limits are
better than they were before so there's
still plenty of phase space out there
for
models or ideas that we would not have
yet noticed uh but the truth is we
haven't noticed them yet so and there's
also been more theoretical models
for what dark matter and dark energy
could be but
you know in the absence of experiment
it's hard to really say that any of them
is going to
really stick its neck up above the
others in terms of popularity
robert ruxin dress you says
i'm going through the biggest ideas in
the universe videos and i saw that you
pause when you're writing something on
the virtual blackboard this tells me
that you represent your thoughts and
ideas and spoken words in your mental
model but i'm not sure my question is if
this is true if you're a spoken mental
model type of person there's a famous
example by richard fineman where he
could count in his head and read but
couldn't speak
whereas a friend of his could count in
his head and speak very well but
couldn't read at all i'm wondering what
kind of difference this makes in terms
of math communication skills and so on
do you think that you'd be a better
mathematician if you were a visual
person
um i think this is a very good question
but actually i don't know that much even
about my own um
where i lie on these spectra that you're
indicating in this uh space of
possibilities it is true
i am very bad at talking and writing at
the same time or even talking and
drawing at the same time
and you know i discovered this i knew
every time i teach a course but
certainly i discovered a new when i did
the biggest ideas in the universe videos
so i learned just to mostly shut up
while i'm writing on the board the part
of my brain that is writing and the part
of my brain that is uh supposed to be
talking are certainly overlapping parts
and they can not do both at the same
time um likewise like unlike some people
i cannot really
listen if i'm writing i don't want to be
listening to music with lyrics i don't
want to be hearing words anywhere else
in the world if i'm writing i'm i'm
focusing on those words one one at a
time and i'm very happy to listen to
instrumental music uh
for example now on the other hand uh in
the world of mathematics you know
there's a famous distinction between
algebraists and geometers people who
think more in terms of equations are
more in terms of figures and when it
comes to math i'm more in terms of
figures kind of guy i reason much more
geometrically than algebraically myself
so i do not have any idea how these
different features fit together i think
this is interesting stuff but i haven't
really thought about it that much
vue chau says
as a theorist are you personally excited
when your work is confirmed or refuted
um i mean your we talked a little about
this before with with general relativity
but obviously
my own work i am most excited when it's
confirmed
the as as a as part of
the scientific community
if you have a theory that's refuted it
makes a big difference whether or not
that theory has previously been accepted
or not like to have an idea that someone
just flows out there without any support
yet and then to have it immediately
refuted that's not exciting for anybody
okay
what's exciting is if you have an
accepted idea so you first have it
confirmed and you realize ah this idea
does have some usefulness
and then it's refuted so you realize ah
there's a limit to its usefulness then
both of those are teaching you a
tremendous amount so as an individual i
just want confirmation after
confirmation as a scientist i want a
back and forth between confirmation and
refutation
rob petro says
you've explained on a number of
occasions that ever-ready and branching
happens either instantly or at light
speed specifically one can choose how to
interpret the branching since presumably
there will be equivalent
these will be equivalent from the
perspective of the observers at the
source of the branch my question relates
to how this interpretation interacts
with quantum entanglement if alice and
bob have entangled particles
and travel to a great distance then bob
observes his particles how does
branching happen given that bob will now
know the state of alice's particle
instantaneously and alice when she
observes will know what bob had observed
so this is exactly why i prefer to think
of it in terms of instantaneous
branching all over even though that is
contrary to the spirit of special
relativity even though it's completely
compatible with the letter of the law as
it were because it's a completely
observable effect unobservable effect
if you say that when bob observes his
particle the branching happens instantly
if you're a many worlds person then
there are now two copies of alice
there's an alice in the spin-up branch
now it's in the spin down branch but she
doesn't know she has no idea that there
are now two copies of her because
they're exactly identical copies locally
so one of them will be on the branch
that later when they visit bob will c
spin up the other will later visit bob
and see spin down as everything is
perfectly compatible
if you want to believe in the story
where the branching sort of spreads out
at the speed of light
then you have to have rules
when that spreading out branches overlap
how they reconcile with each other right
so the branch where alice sees spin up
if the spins are initially counter
aligned
has to have the property that when it
joins up with bob's branches it joins up
with the one where bob was been down et
cetera
so that's complicated but you can do it
you can work it out i just think it's a
little bit of complication we don't
really need
sandro stuckey says is microsoft real
we're back in this one i liked the broad
stroke of jodie zuni's account of what
is real but was disappointed in the
answer it gave for his concrete example
of microsoft now i have to decide which
i should trust his theory or my
intuition how does one evaluate a
philosophical theory like nominalism so
this is why i wanted to get to this this
last question here um you know you can
have your own i already discussed that i
think that it's okay to say microsoft
exists in a certain sense
um you know i can i can sue it right
it must exist i can interact with it
causally okay um but okay i get that
it's a slightly different kind of
existence that that's okay in my mind
but then this question how does one
evaluate a philosophical theory like
nominalism um that's it that's a more
interesting one because on the one hand
i do think it's important i think it's
not beside the point where you stand on
these issues
on the other hand
one could take a stance that says it
just doesn't matter what i think about
things like this and so i think the
mattering it does matter but i think the
mattering is indirect um
simply having a stance about whether or
not microsoft is real or not real at a
at a uh philosophical level i mean if
you if you act in exactly the same way
you might say that it doesn't matter but
i think that the stance that stance
would affect how you act ultimately you
know how you think about these things
and also the natural numbers you know or
other mathematical concepts that's
really where i think that's where
nominalism kicks in and has some umph
where it says that uh
numbers don't have independent existence
other than a way of talking about the
physical world
i think that your attitude towards
questions like that
changes how you move forward it changes
how you develop further theories right
you know we're not static in our
understanding of how reality works we're
trying to improve it
and
as you can tell from different
scientists talking to each other in
different ways uh different people have
different
ideas about the best way to improve our
current understanding why why do they
have different
uh
ideas about the best way to interpret
our current to improve our current
understanding why can't everyone just
agree with that and part of it is
because they have different intuitions
about things like this you know
um
i'm thinking about you know how to build
a completely finite quantum mechanical
model because that would potentially
have different ramifications for your
idea about mathematical platonism so
it's literally the case
that a stance towards mathematical
realism is affecting the research work
that i do in that in that case so that's
why i think it's important not because
you're going to make some different
prediction for some scattering
experiment at the lhc but it changes how
you think about the universe and
therefore how you go about being a
theoretical physicist and
even though some of us get paid to do it
we are all theoretical physicists at
some level we are all
developing theories about the world and
using those theories to get through the
day so it's something that matters for
everybody
john stout says forces are mediated by w
and z bosons gluons possibly gravitons
and photons mediate electromagnetism but
the way we generate electrical power and
magnetism is to move electrons
so it would seem that electrons would
mediate electromagnetism can you explain
how photons
how photons do when we are talking i
think you mean what photons do when we
were talking about electricity magnetism
yes
so
electrical charge is carried by
electrons it is not carried by photons
so electricity and electrical power come
about because we move charges around and
so electrons play a crucial role in
doing that but the forces that
accelerate those electrons right f
equals ma forces mass times acceleration
if the electron is accelerating to start
go from being stationary to being moving
in a power wire why is it doing that the
answer is because of photons or more
broadly because of the electromagnetic
fields right that the photons are
excitations of so it really is the
electromagnetic field that provides what
we call the force
of course you know i can say this also
that the whole
separation
of things into you know particles and
forces is a little bit old-fashioned as
i've just said a little while ago it's
all quantum fields interacting with each
other that's all that matters at the end
of the day and whether you want to call
one a force one a particle or whatever
is kind of up to you in some sense
alex siegel says according to my
understanding of the holographic
principle the maximal entropy in a
region scales with the radius squared or
the surface area of that region
in other words the density or average of
the maximal entropy scales with
two-thirds of the power of the total
for extremely large volumes this density
would be quite low could this explain
the expansion of the universe the
entropy of the universe is ever
increasing so the volume must go to make
room for the entropy
um
i was with you there for a while like
your statements about the holographic
principle etc are completely correct
could it explain the expansion of the
universe no it has nothing to do with
the expansion of the universe or with
the increase of entropy of the universe
because the expansion the universe
doesn't need explaining we know the
explanation of it we have einstein's
equation we have cosmology we have the
friedman equation in cosmology
the universe expands because there's a
relationship between energy density and
the curvature of space-time and the
expansion of the universe is one version
of the curvature of space-time so if
there is matter and energy in the
universe it must either expand or
contract or be very very delicately
balanced on a hilltop in between but
that's unstable as we learned a long
time ago so we don't need an explanation
for that um and in fact the uh
if you if you continue on as we talked a
little bit earlier in this very long ama
podcast
about uh the eventual equilibration of
the universe into a de sitter phase
where there's no
stars or galaxies hanging around just
empty space with a positive cosmological
constant
the horizon size around a point will
asymptote to a fixed number it will not
continue to grow
so the entropy inside that horizon size
will stay fixed but the universe is
still expanding in some very real sense
um overall that's what decider space
does so it's not really a connection
there as you might have guessed
phil says could you give a rough
explanation of how spin arises from
unifying special relativity and quantum
mechanics don't be afraid to be a bit
technical in your answer
uh actually i think it's easy to give a
accurate answer because it doesn't arise
from unifying special relativity in
quantum mechanics it's perfectly
okay to have spin in non-relativistic
quantum mechanics in fact usually when
we first encounter spin in quantum
mechanics it's in the context of a
non-relativistic theory a single spin
one-half particle a single cubit right
is something we can easily talk about in
non-relativistic qm
uh i think what you're referring to is
the fact that when we do relativistic
quantum mechanics we for reasons that we
talked about already earlier in the
podcast uh we immediately go to field
theory
and there in the context of field theory
it is sensible to be a little bit more
systematic about how to implement the
symmetries of lorenz and variance
rotational and variance boosts and
translations and all that the whole
poincare group as we call it of
symmetries so you look at all the
different representations of these
symmetry groups and you find they fall
into different classifications and the
different classifications have different
spins so spin sort of arises from this
attempt to be systematic but it also
would have arisen from an attempt to be
systematic in non-relativistic quantum
mechanics if you had just had the
galilean symmetries that included
rotations you would also have found
representations that include spin one
half particles and spin one particles
and so forth so i don't really think
that there's any necessary connection
there
christopher matthews says if we're going
to finally achieve the theory of
everything in the foreseeable future do
you think the major breakthrough will
come from the theoretical side or from
the experimental side
um
i mean the obviously the answer is i
don't know we don't know right
predicting the future of major
breakthroughs is a difficult thing to do
um it could come either way honestly i
think that right now there are no
experiments that are being done
which have the character that
if they get a certain result that will
give us a huge clue about what the
theory of everything is and if they get
another result we won't
um if the lhc somehow finds a whole
bunch of supersymmetric particles or
something like that that would be that
would count
as evidence in a certain direction and
still wouldn't be definitive for example
you can have super symmetry even though
string theory is wrong right
uh so there's no it's not like close to
homing in on a theory of everything but
it might point us in a in a certain kind
of direction
but we have already turned on the lhc
and the easy chances for finding super
symmetry have not panned out so
therefore that doesn't seem uh like the
best way to bet right now i think
back before the lhc i recently looked
back at my predictions blog post for the
lhc and i put a 60 chance
on finding super symmetry um so yeah
that was sort of hedging my bets right
60 is almost 50 which almost means you
have no idea but i only put a 3 chance
on finding the higgs boson and nothing
else which seems to be the way things
are going so far so i'm still hopeful
they find something so i don't uh
be put in the situation of having my
three percent chance come out right
depthy amasuria says
when we talk about the cosmological
events we use time scales such as 10
minus 3 33 seconds after the big bang
what is the justification for using what
appears to be a universal time clock for
such phenomena
well justification is twofold number one
the big bang even though it doesn't
exist the big bang is just a singularity
in the equations uh indicating that you
need to do better but in classical
general relativity there is something
called the big bang which is a moment in
time right so it is a starting moment so
it provides a beginning for your clocks
and number two cosmologically there is a
rest frame right i know in relativity
there's no preferred rest frame in
spacetime but when you have space time
plus matter and energy
like you have here on earth
there are rest frames that are kind of
better or at least more um
more obvious to use more natural than
others here on earth it makes sense that
we measure the speed of moving vehicles
with respect to the ground rather than
respect to the sun or something like
that likewise in the universe there is a
rest frame given by the rest energies
and velocities of particles in the
universe if you're standing at some
point in the early universe you will
either be at rest or at motion with
respect to the surrounding plasma of
particles so in that rest frame there is
a natural way to calculate time
calculate the time of a particle that is
at rest in that rest frame and that's
what you do that's the today the rest
frame that is at rest with respect to
galaxies and stars and things like that
so there's a natural clock to use and
it's more or less universal
wesley claire says when making personal
decisions do you actually calculate your
credence for example how to weigh
different consumer products how to spend
leisure time etc
um not you know implicitly i do i mean i
certainly do in scientific context but
in personal decision context i don't
usually it's not really a matter of
comparing different expected values
because there's not a lot of randomness
in the
calculation right if i'm saying like do
i want to have pizza tonight or chinese
food
it's not like well there's a 50 chance
that pizza will will make me happy or
whatever i know more or less i can
accurately predict how happy the pizza
will make me how happy the chinese food
will make me so credences don't usually
come in to the calculation but in some
cases they're definitely there in the
background
alexander rowe says how accurate can
physics be described without using the
equations it's hard to say exactly
because it depends what you mean you
know any equation can just be translated
into words right um the einstein tensor
is proportional to the energy momentum
tensor and the constant proportionality
is 8 pi g
there that is a sentence but it contains
exactly the content of einstein's
equation of general relativity and i
could even
attach vocabulary words to express what
i mean by the einstein tensor and the
energy momentum tensor so i think maybe
what you mean is
how accurate an idea can you get about
what physics is saying
without referring to the specific
quantitative quantitative relations that
we call the laws of physics
right um
so the comparing einstein's equation
whether it's in symbolic form or verbal
form
to
a sentence of the form
the curvature of space-time is caused by
energy and momentum something like that
and you know i think you can go pretty
far understanding the principles of
physics just on the basis of those
verbal descriptions but you're always
missing something um
especially because you
it's not because
saying that the curvature of space time
is caused by energy
is uh
not including the particular
quantitative value of the coefficient
right that's not the problem the problem
is that if all you have are those words
and you have no idea what the
mathematical concepts are
then you don't really know what is meant
by the phrase the curvature of
space-time because in einstein's
equation the curvature of space-time
that matters is a particular
representation of it a particular
characterization of the curvature called
the einstein tensor there's other
features of the curvature of space-time
that are not included in the einstein
tensor that are irrelevant to it etc
there are other ways of thinking about
the curvature of space-time so that
verbal expression is just incomplete
it's not the whole story it doesn't tell
you everything so unless you really are
going to put in the efforts to
understand the concepts behind the
equations um you can get a rough idea
what physics is saying but not a very
accurate idea i would say um so i think
that i mean that's a big part of the
motivation behind the biggest ideas in
the universe like i said i'm not
teaching you how to be a physicist
in these books i'm not teaching you how
to manipulate the equations but i want
you to understand the equations well
enough to really appreciate what it
means to say the curvature of space-time
is driven by matter and energy i think
you if you read the book you really will
be able to understand what that means if
even if you're not a physicist yourself
jeffrey siegel says do you think the
republican party can survive the damage
to their moral authority due to their
bald-faced lies and attempts to
undermine the electoral process or
conversely do you think the country can
survive if such a republican party is
successful in taking the house and
senate in the midterms in the presidency
in 2024
you know since you're phrasing the
question in terms of can the republican
party survive
yeah a hundred percent i have no doubt
that it can survive that's different
than will it survive uh you know these
political questions should never be
thought of as absolutes oh this can't
happen if this goes this way you can be
surprised social systems we can be
surprised i can be surprised social
systems are complex
multi-causal and hard to predict so
i could easily see a future in which the
republican party you know devotes itself
to lying and undermining the electoral
process and fails
and yet just keeps trying for a long
time uh or maybe it keeps trying for a
while that fails and therefore it
switches its strategy to something else
or it succeeds right and it succeeds and
it changes the rules of voting and
representation so that it just keeps
succeeding it builds and builds in its
own um success strategies and then
it just perpetuates for a very long time
and the country can survive likewise i
mean like i said before there's sort of
a nightmare scenario where we have a dem
uh failure of democracy and people are
happy with that
right and the republicans are just
ruling for the next hundred years uh
these are all plausible scenarios for
the future you know the we can debate
the relative likelihood of them and we
can debate
uh how seriously to take them and what
to do about them but there's no doubt
that there are possibilities i think
it's just a huge mistake whenever you're
thinking about
politics or future history to think that
you know better than you really do that
things are absolutely likely or
impossible or or what have you i like to
keep a very very open mind when it comes
to planning for the future in these
political questions
jordan williams says i often describe
myself as a hardcore atheist and find
religions especially the monotheistic
deities primitive relics
however on another level it seems
coincidental that quarks and electrons
have somehow organized themselves into
conscious beings ultimately the universe
theorizing about itself
does it seem possible or likely that
there's some sort of mind very loosely
defined behind our comprehension at work
uh so first i think it's very
interesting that you think that the
monotheistic deities are especially
primitive relics
so presumably the pantheistic deities
polytheistic deities are i should say
are uh less primitive i don't know
that's a that's a different take i'm not
sure you wanted to say that but it's a
defensible take um and secondly i no i
don't think it is likely in any sense
that there is a mind behind
uh our the ability of we human beings uh
to be conscious and aware even though
we're just made out of quarks and
electrons um
to me that's just the lesson of what
we've learned about emergence and and
complexity that you can have very very
simple underlying pieces organized uh
organized themselves in some sense just
under the mindless
purposeless working out of physical laws
into very complicated information
processing systems it seems there seems
to be no difficulty in having that
happen of course there's lots of
difficulties in figuring out the
specific things that did happen in human
history um so that's plenty work to be
done but i see no obstacles to to make
me say well this can't work we gotta
think of outside the box and imagine
that there's some mind behind it all now
you do say does it seem possible or
likely
those are two very very different
questions does it seem possible or
likely it's not likely but i think it's
certainly possible sure it's absolutely
possible you're welcome to contemplate
that possibility
brian tidmore says uh in goodwill
hunting assuming you've seen the movie
there's a scene in which matt damon
burns what could be a mathematical proof
as it burns he says it's not his fault
that he was born with the ability to
understand that level of math
is there any truth to this idea that
some people have brains capable of
higher computational understanding than
others are there any quantum theories
that you yourself are unable to
comprehend
uh taking the last question first i mean
there's certainly quantum theories that
i don't comprehend because i you know
there's a lot of quantum theories out
there a lot of models of different
things in field theory and condensed
matter physics and in other areas of
physics i'm not trying to comprehend
them it's not like i've tried and failed
uh are there any that even if i really
really tried and put my brain to it i
would fail to comprehend
maybe i don't know i doubt it honestly
because you know these are made up by
other human beings and they did the hard
work and making them up once they're
made up i can i can really sit down and
try to comprehend them i don't think
that's really a stumbling block there um
you know about human brains
it seems pretty likely that some are
more powerful than others just very
naturally right uh some people are
taller than others some people have
different hair color than others you
know people are different and their
brains should be different also that
makes perfect sense to me
but
i do think that we are often far too
quick to jump from that very anodyne
statement human beings are different
from each other to some determinism or
some almost magical power that oh well
some people do math and some people
don't
right some people can just see the math
without really even trying very hard now
there are stories out there of savants
in mathematics that just you know see a
math problem and solve it in their
brains um
but for the overwhelming majority of
cases including super genius
mathematicians what you're actually
seeing is the result of a lot of hard
work you know even the best
mathematicians out there have to work
really really hard to understand what's
going on to think about proving new
theorems and so forth and what you see
is the final product and it can look
miraculous and therefore when hollywood
portrays it they portray it as
miraculous but really
there's a lot of work going on that
would not make good cinema but it is the
bread and butter of uh making progress
in these areas
carlos nunez says
is there any movie that you've watched
several times
oh yeah i mean sure you know look i was
what
11 or 12 years old when star wars came
out i was a that target audience for the
first movie ever uh where people just
kept going back over and over again to
see it and i was definitely among those
people you know i saw it maybe like
three times at the time not 20 times
like some people did but
uh you know that was definitely part of
the experience
raiders of the lost ark likewise uh etc
and you know more in in my maturity as
it were um there are definitely movies
that i think are favorites and i'm happy
to watch over and over again whether
it's you know old classics like
casablanca or uh newer ones like brazil
that i can just uh enjoy many many times
and you know i don't mind there's i
watch movies on tv mostly now right
especially because there's a pandemic
etc so there's a movie i'm sure i've
watched the harry potter movies several
times just because sometimes they're on
tv in the background i i mentioned
earlier in the podcast that i cannot
write
when there are spoken words going on
whether it's music with lyrics or
tv or talk shows or podcasts or whatever
i need no words around me
my wife jennifer is very different she
loves to have sort of things that she's
already seen on tv in the background
while she is writing whether it's
midsummer murders or uh harry potter
movies or whatever so just one way or
the other you're going to see a lot of
movies several times
louis b says can you put cream into your
coffee without thinking about the
universe uh no i cannot um happily
number one i don't put cream into my
coffee i drink coffee lot but it's
always black
and number two i can never stop thinking
about the universe the universe is all
around us you should be thinking about
all the time at least i know i am
napoleon's corporal says on several past
episodes the subject of misinformation
and how it spreads has come up can
opinion when clearly identified as such
ever be deemed to be misinformation and
can it ever be right to suppress or
censor it
um
you know i i think the simple answer is
that no opinions are not misinformation
and they generally should not be
suppressed the only hesitation i have
here is you're putting the word ever in
there twice
and i don't think these are questions
about which we should be absolutist um i
think it's a mistake i think it's it's
exactly that clarity of values trap that
teen wen uh warned us about don't you
know think about what is happening here
you know the question is not
let's invent some principle that is
absolute can never be violated the
question is what's the best thing to do
in this complicated situation i am uh
overall as a my my impulses are let
people have whatever opinions they want
and spread them however they want
um and hopefully better opinions will
fight back against them but i can
imagine there are counter examples that
there are cases where doing that would
be really bad uh i don't have a complete
theory of that that's why i'm a
physicist not
a legislator
i think it's an interesting question an
important question but even if my
inclination is let everyone say and
think whatever they want
i'm very open to the possibility that
there can be
circumstances under which that's not a
good idea
murray cantor says i am a good bayesian
however this conundrum is a bit puzzling
we are supposed to update our beliefs
based on the evidence doesn't that
assume we're 100 confident in the
evidence if not do we have to account
for the uncertainty of the evidence and
look for evidence of the truth of the
evidence this seems to lead to some
infinite applications of bayesian rule
has this ever been addressed
well i'm sure it has been addressed but
i think that it doesn't necessarily lead
to an infinite application i think you
just have to
be aware that what you are perceiving
does not necessarily map directly onto
reality okay and this is always good um
advice so if i think that i am seeing a
picture of a duck in front of me
um i should be aware maybe i'm not
seeing that maybe my brain is being
tricked maybe i'm hallucinating maybe
i'm just making a mistake maybe it's an
optical illusion
those should be part of my credences and
so your interpretation of the evidence
you get as something is happening in the
world should always come with some error
bars with some uncertainties attached to
it but once you attach those
uncertainties for some good reason i
don't think you need to attach
uncertainties the uncertainties and
uncertainties to the uncertainties of
the uncertainties etc you can stop once
you have the uncertainties attached to
your evidence and your likelihood
functions and so forth
dlp says do you think ethical arguments
work the same way that mathematical
proofs do just starting from different
axioms and concerning different entities
or are there logical steps that are
valid in one but not the other
i think it's basically the same idea you
know
in in the sense that i think that
mathematical
proofs are just a subset of logical
arguments right
um deductions of conclusions from
starting points or from agreed upon
things about the world
um
there is that's not the only kind of
reasoning that we can do out there in
the world um science is a little bit
different but it can still be put into
the same broad category right in science
we don't have axioms that we hold to be
100 reliable we do our best to um get
the best explanation of a set of
complicated pieces of data that we can
and there's always
some error bars some some probability
that we're wrong and so forth but
nevertheless within science
we use
deductive reasoning logic in the same
way we use it in mathematics i'd say the
same thing about ethical arguments you
know we might have starting points that
we either agree on or don't
um
but once you agree on your principles if
that's how your reasoning if you have
some principles or you have some
starting points then you use the rules
of logic to um
derive conclusions from there yeah i can
i can hardly imagine another way to do
it i'm not sure so in other words i
think that if people think that they're
doing something different um it's just a
different sort of presentation of the
same thing logic is is more or less
logic now again as i'm saying that out
loud all the footnotes are coming to my
mind there are different
different systems of logic
i mean at the very basic level there's
propositional logic first order logic
second order logic but there's also
subcategories within all of those um
and you can actually you know there's
modal logic for example
and you can potentially either reach
different conclusions or
be able to reach conclusions or not
depending on what system of logic you
are using
those are
fair enough
technical worries that i think don't
usually matter for down-to-earth ethical
questions so i think that roughly
speaking what i said originally is right
you just use logic in the same way in
ethics as everywhere else
with a footnote that using logic is not
quite as simple as we might think if all
we did was to take a single you know
lecture in logic or something when we
were in high school
hilbert spaceman says given that two and
three-dimensional euclidean spaces have
very different properties from each
other what do you see is the utility of
physical theories in lower dimensions
well you know it depends on the physical
theory um sometimes it it the it's much
easier to solve the equations in two or
three dimensions right uh or two at two
spatial dimensions rather than three or
even one spatial dimensions and even
being able to solve the equations in an
unrealistic situation might give you
some insight um if you were instead just
forcing yourself to
always look at the realistic situation
but one where you could never solve the
equations so there's a classic example
earlier in the podcast when i mentioned
um doing looking at the creation of
closed time-like curves time machines in
two plus one dimensional gravity so
three space-time dimensions incredibly
unrealistic
there are different properties of
gravity in three dimensions versus four
dimensions but you still learn something
you still learn something that you might
not have known because the answers that
we got from our theorizing were highly
non-intuitive you wouldn't have guessed
them you had to actually go through the
work
to get there
and from that answer from that
non-intuitive answer you can be inspired
to get some conjectures that might apply
to the real three plus one-dimensional
world
that happens over and over again the
other reason of course is that there are
plenty of physical real cases where for
all intents and purposes the problem
that you're looking at really is just
two spatial dimensions or even one
spatial dimensions you know we talked
earlier in the podcast about electricity
going down wires for a very very good
level of approximation you can treat
that as a one-dimensional problem the
direction along the wire
there are plenty of condensed matter
systems that are two-dimensional
superconductors or you know sheets of
graphene or something like that so even
though there are three dimensions of
space around us that doesn't mean that
they're all being accessed by some
physical system in that case studying
lowers of numbers of dimensions makes
perfect sense
josh bauer says in the field of software
engineering there are several layers of
abstraction at which you can think at
which you can think while ignoring the
details of the lower levels for example
when thinking about writing code you can
ignore what circuits will actually do
when it's executing
this is by design it enables the
creation of complex systems this strikes
me as designed emergence do you think
studies of emergence can learn anything
from the engineered abstraction layers
in software
i mean as a at that level of question
it's always possible sure maybe
um it is an example i agree that there's
absolutely a close resemblance of what
you're describing to you know what we've
been talking about earlier in the
podcast about emergence
on the other hand the reason i'm
hesitating a little bit is that
one of the
salient features of the emergence of
complex systems or even just higher
level systems generally in the real
world is that they are not designed
and there are differences between
designed things and non-designed things
there's just look at a car
versus a cow
you know they're about the same size
but very very different things going on
they both move but they move using very
different methods of locomotion they're
both powered by fuel but the fuel they
use is very very different uh they can
both be damaged but what happens when
they're damaged is completely different
and so forth
for very good reasons because the car
has to be
held in the mind of the engineer of the
car or at least you know pieces of it do
and then the the car as a whole is held
in the mind of some boss engineer
the cow doesn't right the cow can be
infinitely more complex than the car can
really when you get down to the detailed
level the other thing is that the cow is
not designed for any purpose the cow is
just finding its niche in the ecology
whereas there was a reason why the car
was designed so
the design of a car
comes from somebody thinking about the
future they say what will be the need
that is served by me me building this
the design of the cow has nothing to do
with planning for the future okay it's
always what has served um just trying
different things out randomly that's
what natural selection does and in the
current moment asking what works and if
it works you reproduce and send that on
to the future generations
so you know a biological organism will
generally be much more flexible and
multi-purpose
than a technological designed organism
will be because it wasn't designed for
any purpose so it will typically be much
more robust biological organisms are
much better at
repairing themselves than most machines
are on the other hand a purpose-built
machine for one purpose will generally
be enormously better at that purpose
than a biological organism will be you
know cheetahs go very fast nowhere near
as fast as the fastest car or the
fastest rocket ship right
we're better at doing
specific goals by engineering than
biology ever is so i think that even
though it's not a necessary fact as a
matter of practice there are differences
in the styles of higher level behavior
you get and the relationship to lower
levels that arise out of
intelligently designed emergent systems
versus undesigned systems
oleg ruvinsky says can you please
explain the ideal the idea of time
reversal symmetry how it relates to the
arrow of time and how we should think
about it
uh yeah time reversal symmetry is just
the idea
that you know given some laws of physics
and you know if the laws of physics are
the following form you give me the state
of a system
at one moment of time and the state
includes you know newtonian mechanics
both the positions and the momentum of
all the different parts of the system in
quantum mechanics it would just be the
wave function of the system and then the
laws of physics tell you how to evolve
it forward in time
uh you can also evolve it backward in
time that's called reversibility that's
not time reversal symmetry
reversibility says that the amount of
information you have in the state of the
system is the same from moment to moment
so there's a unique map from one moment
of time to the next and you can go
forward or backward using that map
that's reversibility time reversal
invariance is that given the state of
the system there's something i can do to
that state some way that i can change it
in particular
in the case of newtonian mechanics that
way would be reverse all the momenta
and then once i've done that i can run
the system backward in time and it would
undo
the evolution it would have done forward
in time so if you like time reversal
symmetry says take the state now evolve
it forward in time a little bit
time reverse it which means
flip all the momentum and in quantum
mechanics you do other things but
classically you would flip all the
momenta then evolve that backward in
time and the claim is you would get to
the same state you started in sorry you
have to undo the time reversal you have
to undo the momentum flipping that's
time reversal and variance and so in in
quantum field theory time reversal and
variance is violated
in the standard model of particle
physics uh you can do experiments that
show that doesn't quite work
except there's a footnote here um that
what do you mean by time-reversal
symmetry so reversibility was very clear
right
the information is conserved from moment
to moment the definition i gave of time
reversal symmetry
was a little more loosey-goosey because
i say you know evolve forward in time
and then do something to the state
in particular change the direction of
all the motions of the particles but in
quantum mechanics a little more subtle
and
then you can go backward and so the
question becomes is there always
something you can do to the state
so that you could reverse it in time and
get back to where you started is that
necessarily true
and the answer is and i don't think this
is well appreciated i started writing a
paper about this at one point but then
got distracted by other things
the answer is it's an unsurprising
answer which is why i'm not motivated to
write the paper but if your theory is
reversible
if it has the property that the
information in the state
deterministically is carried from moment
to moment in time and can go either
forward or backward
then there is always a set of things you
can do to this date that you can call
time reversal that will be a symmetry of
the system
so
that's clearly true for newtonian
mechanics how do you reconcile it with
the claim that i just made that in
particle physics time reversal symmetry
is broken well it's because particle
physicists have chosen to define time
reversal symmetry badly
or not not badly but they've chosen a
particular definition of what they mean
that turns out to not work for actually
reversing the system now the the if
you're worried that i'm making an overly
strong claim there is another symmetry
called cpt which means charge
conjugation parity reversal and time
reversal parity reversal is changing
directions of space rather than time so
that's not very hard charge conjugation
is basically exchanging particles for
antiparticles and cpt
is conserved in the standard model of
particle physics indeed it needs to be
conserved in any local lorenzen variant
quantum field theory so
what you could do
and this is all in my brain because i
literally wrote about it in my book that
is going to be coming out in september
in the biggest ideas book
you could just define cpt to be what you
meant by time reversal and variance you
could just define t prime equals cpt
and that is a time reversal invariant
symmetry that is absolutely conserved in
the standard model because it has to be
something there has to be such a
symmetry because the underlying
dynamical equations are completely
reversible
and therefore to get to your actual
question well how does it relate to the
arrow of time it doesn't it doesn't
relate to it at all
the arrow of time is a macroscopic
phenomenon that comes about from the
fact that entropy is increasing in the
universe um has nothing to do with time
reversal symmetry it has a lot to do
with reversibility and reversibility if
it's there always implies time reversal
symmetry but the real world has the
feature that the microscopic equations
seem to be reversible the macroscopic
world doesn't and that's where the arrow
of time seems to come from in our real
world so it's just unrelated to time
reversal symmetry
cooper says are there a significant
number of physicists that enjoy visual
astronomy as a hobby for me it's good
for my soul to directly see other
galaxies with just my eyes and some
mirrors in my backyard
i wouldn't say significant numbers
honestly there's absolutely numbers you
know um i was a
astronomy major as an undergraduate so i
definitely did quite a bit of stargazing
through pretty good telescopes uh but
you know as a kid that was never my
thing i was i was a theoretically
inclined guy even as a youngster
you know i've had my own graduate
students or my own colleagues were very
very interested in that and so
uh
but you know still it's a minority i
think of them so i mean visual astronomy
is a wonderful thing like being able to
see the sky with your eyeballs even if
you get a bit of a help from some
telescope that you're carrying on your
back or carrying in your truck or
whatever um it's still pretty amazing
because you know it's kind of
interesting there's a interesting
feature of the world that our sky is not
that interesting i mean it's pretty
interesting the sky at the level of our
um
naked eye if you're really out there in
a dark place and you can see the milky
way and all of its glory and so forth
the milky way is pretty awesome okay
that's the milky way not just as a
galaxy but as a visual sight is pretty
amazing
but stars are not that amazing you know
there's literally points of light i mean
we know that they're very very
interesting close up then when you can
see them there's planetary systems and
nebulae and so forth but you need
telescopes to see all that stuff that's
an interesting fact about the universe
that there's a lot of interestingness
out there but it's far enough away that
we can't see it with our naked eye
but it's right on the edge so that if
you bring a little telescope if it's not
that big you can see some of that stuff
so i think that's just really amazing
that that little bit of technological
boost gives us a qualitatively different
view of the universe and so i think
there's a lot of joy that one can get
out of that
uh having said that i don't do it myself
these days as part of my life
okay and on a similar
note the final question of today's ama
is from matthew mckeever who says
what are your guilty pleasures and how
would you even define guilt in this
context i'm thinking about enjoying
following devoting some amount of time
and energy to something others would
think trivial perhaps mechanical watches
or automobiles if you enjoy
craftsmanship and mechanical technology
for examples
um
yeah you know i would i would push back
on the word guilty i don't think that
you should be guilty about your
pleasures just enjoy your pleasures as
long as you're not hurting anybody else
so i'm not that guilty about my
pleasures i'm in favor of pleasures as a
general rule people should have more of
them um and presciently you put your
finger on one of my main uh pleasures
guilty or not which is mechanical
watches uh you know 10 years ago i had
no interest in mechanical watches i was
happy to wear a cheap electronic watch
um but then i wrote a book
called from eternity to here the quest
for the ultimate theory of time and it
was mostly about the entropy and the
arrow of time and a little bit about
space time and time reversibility as
we've been talking about stuff like that
but you know it's my first trade book i
was very enthusiastic about writing
absolutely everything that could be
thought of and said about this topic so
i did a little bit about time keeping in
the book and i started reading up about
escapements and and things like that and
some somehow i actually got started
reading about the swiss uh the quartz
crisis in swiss mechanical watches for
those of you who don't know you know it
used to be that mechanical watches were
the only watches those are what you had
and then in the late 60s in the 1970s
they invented quartz watches which are
much cheaper and more accurate right so
that's a win-win okay and for
to a large extent the swiss mechanical
watch industry cratered uh the court's
crisis it's called because why would you
spend more money on a watch that is not
as accurate
and finally they figured out a reason to
stay alive um and the reason was that
it's kind of nice to have a an elegant
mechanical machine on your wrist that
serves both as a technological marvel
and as a work of art has a little bit of
jewelry right men don't get to wear
jewelry they don't get to adorn
themselves with accessories that often
but watches are one way that you can do
it um so these days there's a whole
mechanical watch industry uh you know in
the and the price points go from a
hundred dollars to
a million dollars
more more than a million dollars for the
super expensive watches and they're both
they really are technologically quite
impressive
many of them you know depending on how
much you're willing to spend they're
mass-produced but at the higher levels
of paying you're looking at things that
get a lot of individual human attention
along the way
some of them are very interesting in
their designs and some of them are
beautiful and some of them are just kind
of like rugged and manly or
elegant and artistic and beautiful and
so it is it's a wonderful hobby to kind
of get lost in in fact it's very very
dangerous hobby because however much
money you want to spend you can so you
have to keep that under control
happily for me uh i'm not really a
spendthrift i'm not really you know
someone to spend more money than i have
or
want to feel comfortable spending so i'm
not in danger of you know buying hundred
thousand dollar watches even if i could
uh i don't think i ever could could you
ever buy i know people do but like
could you walk around with a hundred
thousand dollar watch on your hand
worried that like it might break i don't
know i don't think i could ever be rich
enough to to to enjoy that um but i like
the level of uh spending that i can do
on it i try to restrain myself from from
buying too many watches i went through a
phase early like we buy a lot of cheap
watches because just one variety and now
i realize it's better to save your money
get a nice watch whenever you want one
and completely you know completely
guilty pleasure in the sense that it's
not practical i can still check the time
on my phone just as well but i like it
that's what a guilty pleasure is i just
like it that's the point but the real
answer to your question is of course as
many people know is basketball like if
you folks knew
how many minutes of my average day was
spent thinking about the philadelphia
76ers you'd be embarrassed for me you
would feel bad you would think that i'm
wasting my time you know i i talk about
lots of things on the internet and so
forth when i'm reading things on the
internet a lot of the time it's about
trade scenarios for the sixers et cetera
and you know at the end of a long day if
there happens to be a sixers game on i'd
be very happy to watch that even though
they're very far away uh technology lets
me watch the games now it's kind of
awesome
again completely impractical but
pleasurable i think that's good i don't
think that you should be you should feel
guilty about it at all so pleasures
let's just call them pleasures and let's
say that pleasures are good things and
with that i cannot think of a better
place to wind up this ask me anything
episode as usual thank you very much for
supporting the mindscape podcast it's a
great ride we're all on and we have in
this new year some pretty awesome new
podcasts coming up so stay tuned bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you